Ho, ho, ho, pimp, Yankee Swap! Ooh, that can only mean one thing. It is time for an Office Christmas episode. Yes, it is. We are taking it back to the beginning with the very first Dunder Mifflin Christmas party. Yes, we are off this week to be with our families for the holidays, but we thought
嘿，嘿，嘿，老鸨，洋基交换礼物！噢，那只能说明一件事。又到了《办公室》圣诞特别集的时候了。是的，没错。我们将回到最初，重温邓德米夫林的第一个圣诞派对。是的，我们这周要休息去和家人过节，但我们觉得
Christmas party would be a great episode to reshare. Lady, before we break down the episode, I have to tell you about a fun creed moment that I missed the first time around. All right, so we learn about another chapter in creed's life. It's in deleted scenes. You've got to hear it. Oscar is going to ask Creed what he eventually
圣诞派对会是一个非常适合重新分享的剧集。各位，在剖析这集之前，我必须告诉你们一个我上次漏掉的关于克里德的有趣时刻。好吧，我们了解到了克里德生活中的另一个篇章。它在删减片段里。你们一定要听听。奥斯卡要问克里德他最后在
got in the Yankee Swap exchange. Here's what Creed has to say. What'd you end up with? Your char radio. You like music, at least? I love it. Actually, you used to have a radio show back in the 70s. Kidding.
洋基交换礼物中得到了什么。克里德是这么说的。你最后拿到了什么？你的车载收音机。你至少喜欢音乐吧？我喜欢。事实上，你在70年代时曾主持过一个广播节目。开玩笑的。
What was your DJ name? Wacky Weed Creed. Oh, my gosh. That sounds real. Was Creed a DJ? OK, I thought the same thing, so I texted him. I said, hey, Creed, oh, were you ever a DJ? And if so, what's your DJ name?
你的DJ名字叫什么？古怪大麻克里德。哦，天哪。听起来真有其事。克里德曾经是个DJ吗？好吧，我也这么想，所以我给他发了短信。我说，嘿，克里德，哦，你以前当过DJ吗？如果是的话，你的DJ名字是什么？
Wacky Weed Creed. He said, no, haha, I only wish. Oh, Creed, there's still time. There's still time. Well, we should probably get into this episode. But first, just a little reminder that Office Ladies was nominated for podcast of the year again at the I Heart Radio Awards, and the winner is decided
古怪大麻克里德。他说，没有，哈哈，我只希望如此。哦，克里德，还来得及。还来得及。好吧，我们或许该进入这一集了。但首先，提醒大家一个小事，《办公室》再次获得了I Heart电台大奖的年度播客提名，而获胜者是由
by who gets the most votes. So you get to vote. And we'd really love it if you did. Yeah, please vote for us. We really want to win. So here's how you vote, you guys. You have to go to Twitter, and you have to tweet, hashtag Office Ladies,
得票最多的人决定的。所以你们可以投票。如果我们能得到你们的投票，我们会非常高兴的。是的，请投我们一票。我们真的很想赢。所以投票方法是这样的，伙计们。你们必须去推特，然后发推文，带上话题“办公室女士”，
hashtag podcast of the year, hashtag I Heart Podcast Awards. That's it. Those three things, you tweet them with the hashtag, and that's your vote. Lady, I've been on Twitter, and I've seen the hashtags coming in, like people voting. And it means so much. It's so exciting.
话题“年度播客”，话题“I Heart播客大奖”。就这样。这三件事，你们把它们发到推特上并带上话题，这就是你们的投票。女士，我一直在推特上，我看到话题不断涌现，就像人们在投票一样。这意味着太多了。太令人兴奋了。
I can't wait to see them. I forgot my Twitter password. I know. And so I'm talking to the Twitter people about how to get back on Twitter. And as soon as I am, I can't wait to see all the votes and all your messages. And I hope you will vote for us, too, lady,
我等不及要看到了。我忘了我的推特密码。我懂。所以我正在和推特的人沟通如何重新登录推特。一登录上去，我就迫不及待地想看到所有的投票和你们所有的留言。女士，我希望你也能给我们投票，
once you have Twitter. I just need my password. So will the Twitter people help me? Thank you. You guys, we love you. We want to wish you a happy holidays. We hope this week is filled with friends and family. Know that we love you.
等你有了推特以后。我只需要我的密码。所以推特的工作人员会帮我吗？谢谢。伙计们，我们爱你们。我们要祝大家节日快乐。我们希望这周充满朋友和家人。请知道我们爱你们。
And thank you so much for listening to Office Ladies every week. And now, here is Christmas Party. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch
非常感谢大家每周收听《办公室女士》。现在，这就是《圣诞派对》。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作
podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Hi, everyone. Ho, ho, ho. This is a big episode.
终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有两个亲历者才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。大家好。嘿，嘿，嘿。这是一集大制作。
It's the Christmas episode. It's the Christmas episode, the very first Christmas episode of The Office. Season two, episode 10. You know, it's not. We call it the Christmas episode. Yeah, we do. Or Christmas episode.
这是圣诞特别集。这是圣诞特别集，是《办公室》的第一集圣诞特别集。第二季，第10集。你知道，其实不是。我们叫它圣诞特别集。是的，我们确实这么叫。或者叫圣诞集。
But it is technically called Christmas Party. What? Yeah, that's the name of this episode. I don't believe you. Christmas Party. I don't believe you. No, I'm kidding. We did.
但它的正式剧名其实叫《圣诞派对》。什么？对，这就是这集的名字。我不信。圣诞派对。我不信。不，开玩笑的。我们确实这么叫。
We call it the Christmas episode. We call it the Christmas episode. Even though there were many more, this is the Christmas episode. I have so much to say. I have 12 typed pages today. It looks like you're holding a mini phone book. I feel like I'm holding a one-act play or something.
我们叫它圣诞节那一集。我们叫它圣诞节那一集。尽管后来还有很多集，但这就是圣诞那一集。我有太多话要说了。我今天打印了12页。你看上去像是在拿着一本迷你电话簿。我觉得我像是在拿着一出独幕剧什么的。
It's very large. And when I came in today, I will share that I refuse to speak to anyone because I said I was saving it for the mic. And I'm saving it for the mic. She did. I tried to make a spell talk with her. And she's like, I'm saving it for the mic.
它非常厚。而且我今天进来的时候，我要分享的是，我拒绝和任何人说话，因为我说我要把这些留给麦克风。我要把留给麦克风。她真的这么做了。我试图跟她搭话。然后她说，我要把这留给麦克风。
I was like, OK, lady, you do you. I was just going to tell you I liked your hair. You've got little pigtails today, and they're real cute. I have plaits. What are plaits? That's what they say in the UK. They're like, oh, look at your plaits. Oh, yeah, they also call bangs fringe.
我当时想，好吧，女士，你随你便。我只是想告诉你我喜欢你的头发。你今天梳了小辫子，真的很可爱。我有辫子。什么是辫子？那是英国人的说法。他们会说，哦，看你的辫子。哦，对，他们也把刘海叫作fringe。
I know. I like it. Yeah. I don't know if you notice my side of the table. Totally filled with note cards. By my side of the table, you guys, I've made a buffet of note cards. Like, I actually have to be aware, like Sam
我知道。我喜欢。对。不知道你们有没有注意到我这一边的桌子。完全堆满了便签卡。伙计们，在我这边的桌子上，我弄了一个便签卡自助餐。就像，我实际上必须注意，就像山姆
is saying to stay in front of the microphone, because I have so many cards. I'm going to have to slide back and forth down my buffet of cards. You love a buffet. I love a buffet, baby. Even a fifth note card. Give me that Vegas buffet. All right, Christmas party written by Mike Shore
说的那样，要待在麦克风前面，因为我有太多的卡片。我得在我的卡片自助餐前来回滑动。你喜欢自助餐。我喜欢自助餐，宝贝。哪怕是第五张便签卡。给我来那个拉斯维加斯的自助餐吧。好吧，《圣诞派对》，由迈克·肖尔编剧，
and directed by Charles McDougal. Here's a synopsis. It's Christmas at Dunder Mifflin. Today is the day of the office holiday party. The group originally plans to have a secret Santa gift exchange, but when Michael doesn't like his gift, he turns it into a Yankee swap. This causes a multitude of confusion and hurt feelings,
查尔斯·麦克杜格尔执导。以下是剧情简介。邓德米夫林的圣诞节到了。今天是公司假日派对的日子。大家原本计划进行一个秘密圣诞老人礼物交换，但当迈克尔不喜欢他的礼物时，他把它变成了一个洋基交换礼物。这导致了众多的困惑和受伤的情绪，
and Michael's solution is then to go out and buy booze, which is against company rules, and to try to get the party back on track. 15 bottles of vodka. That'll do it. So much. Fastback number one. As I've already said, it's our very first Christmas episode,
而迈克尔的解决办法是出去买酒，这违反了公司规定，并试图让派对重回正轨。15瓶伏特加。这招管用。太疯狂了。趣事一。正如我之前所说，这是我们的第一个圣诞特别集，
but we filmed it nowhere near Christmas. No, you never do, because you have to stay ahead. So you're always, it's like Christmas in July kind of thing. Well, we had a fan question from Sarah McGreen. Did US cast members ever have Christmas parties or do a Yankee swap? And if so, what was the best funniest gift someone brought? A lot of people also asked if we exchanged gifts as a cast.
但我们拍摄的时候离圣诞节还早得很。对，你永远不会在圣诞节拍，因为你必须保持超前进度。所以你总是，这有点像七月份过圣诞节的感觉。好吧，我们有一个来自莎拉·麦格林的粉丝提问。美国剧组演员们有没有过圣诞派对或玩过洋基交换礼物？如果有的话，大家带过最好玩、最搞笑的礼物是什么？很多人还问我们剧组演员之间是否互送礼物。
Not at the holidays. We would do what's called a wrap gift, which happens at the end of the season, and we would usually finish filming our seasons in, like, what, April? And then the cast would get together and we'd pull our money and we would buy the crew. Every member of the crew would get a gift from the cast.
节日期间不送。我们会举行所谓的杀青礼物交换，这发生在季度末，我们通常会在比如4月份左右结束我们的季度拍摄？然后演员们会聚在一起，凑钱给剧组买礼物。剧组的每位成员都会收到演员们送的一礼。
And then sometimes, cast members would give each other wrap gifts. Little individual gifts. Yeah. I did host a Yankee swap Christmas party, and I did it every year for a few years. And I actually want to bring it back. I took a few years off because just life kids and stuff
然后有时，演员们会互送杀青礼物。小小的个人礼物。是的。我确实举办过洋基交换礼物圣诞派对，连续好几年，每年都办。我其实想把它重新办起来。我停办了几年，因为生活、孩子和诸如此类的事情
like that. But I hosted a Yankee swap party every year. Oh, yes, you did. And it was a big party, and everyone would come, and it got so rowdy. My favorite person to have at a Yankee swap party is Oscar Nunez. I was going to say Oscar.
占用了时间。但我每年都举办洋基交换礼物派对。哦，是的，你办过。那是个盛大的派对，每个人都会来，而且场面非常喧闹。我最喜欢在洋基交换礼物派对上看到的人是奥斯卡·努涅斯。我正要说奥斯卡。
Oscar. He makes up chants. Like, I remember one of the gifts was like a really lusciously thick, fake ponytail that you ended up being. I took that home. Yeah, I took the fake ponytail. Like, started chants like, ponytail, pony.
奥斯卡。他会即兴编口号。就像，我记得其中一个礼物是一个非常浓密蓬松的假马尾辫，结果被你拿到了。我把它带回家了。对，我拿了那个假马尾辫。就像，开始喊口号，比如“马尾辫，马尾”之类的。
I mean, they're not really creative chants, but you'd be surprised how much they catch on. I remember one year Lee brought a small hand axe. That thing was super popular. The hot trade. Yes, I want to put it out there. Guys, if you're going to a Yankee swap, consider bringing a small axe.
我是说，这些口号其实不太有创意，但你会惊讶于它们是多么容易流行起来。我记得有一年李带了一把小型手斧。那东西超级受欢迎。抢手货。是的，我想在这里提出来。伙计们，如果你要去参加洋基交换礼物，考虑带一把小斧头。
Didn't the next year Lee brought a brand new water hose? A garden hose. A garden hose. That was also a hot item. Really popular. Just like practical household items that maybe you need, but you haven't been buying yourself. Well, the next Yankee swap party I have,
第二年李不是带了一根全新的水管吗？花园水管。花园水管。那也是个热门单品。非常受欢迎。就像实用的家居用品，也许你需要，但你一直没给自己买。好吧，我的下一个洋基交换礼物派对，
I'm actually going to include the kids, because those were adult only. Oh, yeah. And I want to do a family Yankee swap. OK. Like, and invite. The kids are such at the age where they're really getting into it.
我其实打算把孩子们也叫上，因为以前那些只限成人参加。哦，对。我想搞一个家庭洋基交换礼物。好的。就像，邀请他们。孩子们现在正处于真正开始热衷于此的年纪。
We went to one last year. But I want you to know, Jennifer, all the people that used to come. So at the end of the night, there would be these crap gifts that people would not want. And a friend of mine would, unbeknownst to me, hide them around my house. I remember this.
我们去年去过一个。但我想让你知道，珍娜，以前常来的那些人。所以在派对结束时，会剩下一些大家都不想要的垃圾礼物。我的一位朋友会趁我不知情，把它们藏在我房子的各个角落。我记得这事。
And I would find them months later. Like, because he really hid them. Yeah. Like, up, like, sort of on a top shelf by, like, the spare batteries would be like a weird porcelain clown. Yeah. You know? And Zach Woods brought this gift.
几个月后我还会找到它们。因为他是真的很会藏。是的。比如，在某个最高层的架子上，备用电池旁边，会放着一个奇怪的瓷小丑。对吧？扎克·伍兹带了这个礼物。
And he said, Angela, I am the failure of Yankee swap, because he brought a Egyptian. The king, the King Tut thing. It was a King Tut miniature sarcophagus. Yeah. That opened up, and you could put things inside it. And I said, I fought for that. I thought it was really great.
他说，安吉拉，我是洋基交换礼物的失败者，因为他带了一个埃及的东西。法老，图坦卡蒙的东西。那是一个图坦卡蒙的微型石棺。对，能打开，你可以在里面放东西。我说，我为了那个礼物争过。我觉得它真的很棒。
I loved that. Well, it got traded a bunch. And he was like, I don't think anyone likes it. I was like, Zach, you're wrong. I know I'm talking a lot about my Yankee swap party guys, but I was really inspired. Well, this is a side note about Zach Woods. You guys, he played Gabe in later seasons.
我很喜欢那个。好吧，它被交换了好几次。他说，我觉得没人喜欢它。我说，扎克，你错了。我知道我一直在说我的洋基交换礼物派对，伙计们，但我真的是有感而发。好吧，顺便提一下扎克·伍兹的事。伙计们，他在后来的几季中扮演加比。
Yes. And he became a good friend of ours. When my son was born, he did the same thing. He gave me a gift, and he said, I'm so sorry. I'm not good at buying gifts for children. I don't have kids yet. I don't know. And it was this amazing astronaut costume
是的。他成了我们的好朋友。我儿子出生时，他也做了同样的事。他送了我一份礼物，并说，真的很抱歉。我不擅长给小孩子买礼物。我还没有孩子。我不知道该买什么。结果那是一套极其精美的宇航员服装，
that we still have today and used for dress up. I think he's better at buying gifts than he is. I think you are, Zach, just FYI. All right, fast fact number two. This episode was directed by Charles McDougal. Oh, guys, do we have stories about Charles McDougal? I mean. First of all, he was British.
我们到现在还留着，用来角色扮演。我觉得他其实挺擅长买礼物。我觉得你是擅长的，扎克，仅供参考。好吧，趣事二。这一集由查尔斯·麦克杜格尔执导。哦，伙计们，我们有关于查尔斯·麦克杜格尔的故事吗？我是说。首先，他是英国人。
Yes. He's British. Jenna, don't do your accent. I'm bringing out the accent. Guys, I did my spin bike, and now I'm speaking like a Brit. He had directed before us the HBO series, Rome, which, if anyone saw it, is about the Roman Empire and the killing of Julius Caesar.
对。他是英国人。珍娜，别学你的英国腔。我要飙口音了。伙计们，我刚骑完动感单车，现在我说话就像个英国人了。他之前导演过HBO剧集《罗马》，如果有人看过的话，讲的是罗马帝国和尤利乌斯·凯撒遇刺的故事。
It is epic. It's also brutal. It's brutal. They shot in Malta. There was chariots and horses and people getting impaled. Yes. And so he went from that to our quiet little Dunder Mifflin office.
那真是史诗级的。而且也很残酷。非常残酷。他们在马耳他拍摄。有战车、马匹，还有被刺穿的人。是的。所以他从那种大场面来到了我们安静的小邓德米夫林办公室。
Hello, Christmas party. Hello, Christmas party. And you guys, the directors that had directed us prior to him were Ken Kuapas, who might be the quietest human on the planet. Correct. He says, you know, when he wants to start a scene, he just says, go ahead. And when he gives a note, he'll say, Jenna, you know what?
你好，圣诞派对。你好，圣诞派对。而且伙计们，在他之前导演过我们的导演有肯·夸帕斯，他可能是地球上最安静的人了。没错。他说，你知道的，当他想开始一个场景时，他只会说，开始吧。当他给出意见时，他会说，珍娜，你知道吗？
No, just go ahead. Yeah. That's Ken Kuapas. Yeah. You all heard Paul Feig. Paul Feig is like, hey gang, how's it going? Hey, we're going to have fun today. OK, action.
不，就直接开始吧。对。那就是肯·夸帕斯。是的。你们都听过保罗·费格。保罗·费格就像是，嘿，伙计们，最近怎么样？嘿，我们今天要玩得开心点。好的，开拍。
Yeah. Charles McDougal rolls in. We're all sitting at our desks. Quietly about to start the first scene. And he goes, wait, brace yourself. Brace yourself. He goes, actors, action. Yes.
对。查尔斯·麦克杜格尔大步走进来。我们都坐在办公桌前。安安静静地准备开始第一场戏。然后他说，等等，做好心理准备。做好心理准备。他说，演员们，开拍。是的。
We, I thought Phyllis peed herself a little. I tinkled. I tinkled. I mean, I was terrified. I jumped straight up. He was like, oh my gosh. We were like, what's happening? What's happening?
我们，我觉得菲莉丝当时差点吓尿了。我漏了一点。我漏了一点。我是说，我当时吓坏了。我直接跳了起来。他当时就像，哦天哪。我们当时想，发生什么事了？发生什么事了？
Is Tom Cruise busting through the ceiling any minute? I'm telling you, that first day, the first moment of every scene, we all looked like deer in headlights. We would flinch. We would flinch, and then we would go into scene. But then, you guys, we just grew to love this guy. He would say things like, we'd be working on a scene. And he'd be like, all right, you know, let's go again.
难道汤姆·克鲁斯随时会破顶而入吗？我告诉你们，那头一天，每一场的第一个镜头，我们看起来都像是在强光照射下的鹿。我们会畏缩。我们会畏缩一下，然后才进入剧情。但是后来，伙计们，我们渐渐爱上了这家伙。他会说这样的话，我们在拍一场戏。然后他会说，好吧，你知道的，我们再来一次。
Actors, nearly there. Yes. Nearly there. And then he one time said, he said, all right, everyone, that was good for cameras. Actors, better this time? Yeah. We're like, oh, OK.
演员们，快完成了。是的。快完成了。然后他有一次说，他说，好吧，大家，这个镜头画面很好。演员们，这次能更好吗？是的。我们当时想，哦，好吧。
And then as we try to be better this time. As we got into the episode more and the party started, he would walk up to me and be like, Angela, remember, you're really pissed. You're really pissed now. And he sort of, and I'm going to get into it. It's on like four or five note cards. But he sort of highlighted the level of, I called it,
然后当我们试图这次表现得更好时。随着我们对这集的深入拍摄和派对的开始，他会走到我面前说，安吉拉，记住，你真的很生气。你现在真的很生气。他有点，而且我会详细讲这部分。我在四五张便签卡上都写了。但他有点强调了那个程度，我称之为，
Angela's pissed off-ness. Yeah. And it had like, it was like building to a crescendo. And so towards the end, he would just yell before a big take in the party. He'd be like, all right, everyone, happy. Angela pissed and action. Yes.
安吉拉的愤怒程度。对。而且它就像是在层层递进。所以在快结束时，在派对上的一个大镜头开拍前，他就会直接大喊。他会说，好吧，大家，开心。安吉拉生气，然后开拍。是的。
It was amazing. It was amazing. I just think it's so interesting that he went from filming all these chariots to filming people in a circle. Yeah. Sitting in a circle. What was that like for him?
这太棒了。这太棒了。我只是觉得很有趣，他从拍摄所有这些战车转向拍摄围坐成一圈的人。是的。围坐成一圈。对他来说那是什么感觉？
On desk chairs. Yes. OK. Fast fact number three, Bob Vance, Vance Refrigeration. We meet Phyllis's boyfriend. Yes. Her new boyfriend. He works across the hall.
坐在办公椅上。是的。好的，趣事三，鲍勃·范斯，范斯冷冻公司。我们遇到了菲莉丝的男友。是的。她的新男友。他在大厅对面工作。
He's played by Bobby Ray Schaefer. He went on to do 24 episodes of The Office, including our finale. So here's a little tidbit. Mike Scherr, our writer, said that the way that Bob Vance always introduces himself as Bob Vance, Vance Refrigeration, is based on a friend of his, actor Hayes MacArthur, who he says for years would introduce himself as Hayes MacArthur,
他由鲍比·雷·谢弗饰演。他后来在《办公室》里演了24集，包括我们的最后一集。所以这里有个小花絮。迈克·肖尔，我们的编剧，说鲍勃·范斯总是自我介绍为“鲍勃·范斯，范斯冷冻公司”的方式，是基于他的一个朋友、演员海斯·麦克阿瑟，他说海斯多年来总是自我介绍为海斯·麦克阿瑟，
Chicago, Illinois. Hayes MacArthur, Chicago, Illinois. You guys, you might know Hayes. He would later go on to star with Rashida Jones on Angie Tribeca, which was created by Steve and Nancy Carell. Small world. Small world.
伊利诺伊州芝加哥。海斯·麦克阿瑟，伊利诺伊州芝加哥。伙计们，你们可能认识海斯。他后来与拉什达·琼斯一起主演了史蒂夫和南希·卡瑞尔创作的《安吉·特里贝卡》。世界真小。世界真小。
But I feel comfortable sharing that story about Hayes, because I know him as well. And Mike said it on the DVD commentary. So he shared that with us on set. But since he put it out there, I was like, well, Mike, you already said it, so I'm going to share it here. Yeah. Well, you know what?
但我分享关于海斯的故事觉得很自在，因为我也认识他。而且迈克在DVD评论音轨里说过这事。所以他在片场跟我们分享过。既然他都已经公开了，我想，好吧，迈克，你既然已经说过了，那我就在这里分享一下。好吧，你知道吗？
I think that some people do that. I mean, I know in my hometown, I'm from a very small town in Texas. And there are people in my town that we, no one ever says just their first name. I don't know why, but my mom's really good friend. Her first name is Sue, and her last name is Dean. But every one of the town calls her Sue Dean.
我觉得有些人就是这样。我的意思是，我知道在我的家乡，我来自德克萨斯州的一个小镇。镇上有些人，我们从来没有人只叫他们的名字。我不知道为什么，但我妈妈的死党。她的名字叫苏，姓迪恩。但镇上的每个人都叫她苏·迪恩。
Oh, yeah. Hi, Sue Dean. How are you, Sue Dean? It'd be like, Jenna Fisher. How are you, Jenna Fisher? I'm good, Jenna Fisher. I mean, so there are some people whose names just, you just do that.
哦，是的。嗨，苏·迪恩。你好吗，苏·迪恩？这就好像是，珍娜·费舍尔。你好吗，珍娜·费舍尔？我很好，珍娜·费舍尔。我的意思是，所以有些人的名字就是这样，你自然而然就会这么叫。
Yeah. Well, we had some fans right in and ask, why does he always say Bob Vance, Vance Refrigeration? It was inspired by one of Mike's friends. I love it. Many people, before we go to break, many people wrote in to tell us that Mindy's hair is down. I've maybe not received so many notes in this episode.
对。好吧，有些粉丝写信来问，为什么他总是说“鲍勃·范斯，范斯冷冻公司”？这是受到迈克的一个朋友的启发。我太喜欢了。很多人，在我们休息之前，很多人写信来告诉我们明迪的头发是披散着的。我可能没有在这集里收到过这么多的指出错误的笔记。
No, it's down. No, it's partially up. It's partially up. Oh, well, Jennifer Donette said that Mindy's hair is down. Jennifer Donette, I'm going to send you a screen grab. I mean, maybe she means down because it's not in the French twist. It's not in the French twist, but she has had a few.
不，是披散的。不，是半扎起来的。是半扎的。哦，好吧，詹妮弗·多内特说明迪的头发是披散着的。詹妮弗·多内特，我要给你发个截图。我是说，也许她说的是披散着，是因为它没有盘成法式发髻。它没有盘成法式发髻，但她确实有过几次。
It's half up, half down. She's had a few half up, half downs, but I would say there's more down than up. Jennifer, there's more down than up. That's what she said? Well, I hope she doesn't say that. Wow. We would hope there's more up than down.
一半扎起，一半放下。她梳过几次一半扎起，一半放下的发型，但我觉得放下的比扎起的多。詹娜，放下的比扎起的多。她是这么说的吗？嗯，我希望她没这么说。哇。我们希望扎起的多于放下的。
All right, let's go to break. All right, let's go to break. All right, so let's dive in here. We've got the cold open in the very first few seconds. Pam is stuffing the Christmas envelopes. The Christmas photo. Yeah. Right?
好了，我们休息一下。好了，我们休息一下。好了，那我们深入正题吧。在头几秒钟里有精简版片头。帕姆正在装圣诞信封。圣诞照片。对吧？
She's doing the Christmas card mass mailing. The Christmas card. I did this at 1-800-DENNEST. Oh, you did the 1-800-DENNEST company Christmas card mailing? I did. I volunteered, and you got to hop off the phone so you didn't have to talk to people about, like, their rotten teeth.
她在批量邮寄圣诞贺卡。圣诞贺卡。我在 1-800-DENNEST 干过这活。哦，你做过 1-800-DENNEST 公司圣诞贺卡的邮寄工作？我做过。我自愿去的，这样你就可以挂断电话，不用跟别人谈论比如他们烂掉的牙齿之类的事。
And I would go in the mailroom, and they'd be playing Christmas music, and I'd have a cup of tea, and I would just stuff envelopes all day, and I was so happy. Oh, yeah. I did many, many mass mailings as an administrative assistant. I'd have to bind things, copy on both sides, collate, bind, and mail. I'm very happy doing those things.
然后我会去收发室，他们会放着圣诞音乐，我有一杯茶，我就一整天都在装信封，我太开心了。哦，是的。作为行政助理，我做过很多很多批量邮寄。我得装订文件，双面复印， collate，装订，然后邮寄。我很乐意做这些事情。
OK, but the photo was our cast photo that we took our Christmas photo. It was not our Christmas photo. What? Oh, yeah. It was. Listen, I maybe got a little too obsessed with it, but I thought I recognized it.
好吧，但那张照片是我们拍圣诞照片时的演员合影。那不是我们的圣诞照片。什么？哦，是的。就是。听着，我可能对此有点太痴迷了，但我以为我认出来了。
I street-capped it. Me too. It's our season one publicity photo from the pilot. You're right, because I'm sitting in the front. Oh, my gosh. And we're not wearing any Christmas stuff. Oh, Jenna, good catch. I totally just thought it was our Christmas picture.
我在街景图里看到了。我也是。那是我们在试播集中的第一季宣传照。你说得对，因为我坐在最前面。哦，天哪。而且我们没穿任何圣诞服装。哦，詹娜，好眼力。我完全以为那是我们的圣诞照片。
Well, we had a fan question from Pizuki. Did anyone keep a copy of the holiday card Pam is stuffing into the envelopes at the beginning? Well, I don't have a copy of the card, but I have a copy of that picture hanging in my office, and I examined it against the card that Pam is putting into the envelopes. Well, remember in the pilot.
嗯，我们收到了粉丝 Pizuki 的一个问题。有没有人留了一份帕姆在开头塞进信封里的那张节日贺卡的副本？嗯，我没有卡片的副本，但我办公室里挂着那张照片的副本，我拿它和帕姆塞进信封里的卡片进行了对比。嗯，还记得在试播集里。
Who's my detective? Henriette. Thank you so much, CSI office ladies. Henriette is in that photo. Henriette is in the photo on my wall, because she was in the pilot. They photoshopped Kate's head onto Henriette's body for the picture I'm stuffing into the envelope
谁是我的侦探？亨丽埃特。非常感谢，办公室女士 CSI。亨丽埃特在那张照片里。亨丽埃特在我墙上的照片里，因为她在试播集中。他们把凯特的头PS到了亨丽埃特的身体上，用来做我塞进信封里的那张照片
in this episode. I really want that card. Dang it. Yeah, because I can see it's Henriette's hand on her hip in the sweater that's hanging in my office, but Kate's face. Way to go, Jenna. So far, we've covered one second of the episode. That happens in the first one to three seconds.
在本集中。我真的很想要那张卡片。该死。对，因为我能看出挂在我办公室毛衣上那只手是亨丽埃特的，但脸是凯特的。干得好，詹娜。到目前为止，我们只讲了这一集的第一秒。那是头一到三秒发生的事。
The next thing that happens is that Michael and Dwight enter with the tree, and it's really way too big. It's way too big. It goes through the ceiling. I feel like this is a little nod to Christmas vacation. Yes. You know, with Chevy Chase and that enormous tree. Yes, well, do you remember when we were on set, about three
接下来发生的事是迈克尔和德怀特搬着圣诞树进来，真的太大了。太大了。直接顶到了天花板。我觉得这有点在向《疯狂圣诞假期》致敬。是的。你知道的，切维·切斯和那棵巨大的树。是的，好吧，你还记得我们在片场的时候，当他们把它推上去时，大概有三
or four times when they pushed it up, the ceiling towel actually fell down and would fall on Steve's head. And then they'd have to brush him off with a little brush and fix his hair. Little pieces of white sort of like particle looking stuff all over the ground, because the ceiling kept busting apart. I loved that Kevin cuts the top of the Christmas tree
四次天花板的瓷砖真的掉了下来，还砸到了史蒂夫的头上。然后他们得用一个小刷子帮他刷掉碎屑，整理发型。地上到处都是白色的那种类似颗粒状的小块，因为天花板不断碎裂。我喜欢凯文用切纸机切掉圣诞树顶部的桥段
with a paper trimmer. Yeah, I just thought that was such a nice touch. Well, it makes sense, it's what we'd have. It's what we would have. Yeah. OK, I did kind of an Angela thing. What's that? Did you drink rosé during the day?
。对，我只是觉得这个细节太棒了。嗯，这很合理，这就是我们会做的。这就是我们会做的。对。好吧，我有点像安吉拉了。什么事？你在白天喝了桃红葡萄酒吗？
I did not, but I did. I wrote down everybody's Christmas outfits. I love this, so did I. You did? OK, let's do it. Let's do it. All right, I noticed that Michael has a Christmas tie. Yes, he does.
我没有，但我确实这么做了。我写下了每个人的圣诞服装。我喜欢这个，我也是。你写了？好吧，我们开始吧。开始吧。好吧，我注意到迈克尔系了一条圣诞领带。是的，他系了。
It has a Santa on it and some snowmen. Go. Christmas tie, Kevin. Yes, snowmen, wintry scene. All right, you and I both only have a Christmas pin and Christmas earrings. You have Christmas ornament earrings, I have Christmas stocking earrings,
上面有圣诞老人和一些雪人。继续。圣诞领带，凯文。是的，有雪人，冬日景色。好吧，你和我身上都只有一枚圣诞胸针和圣诞耳环。你戴着圣诞装饰品耳环，我戴着圣诞袜子耳环，
and we both have a version of a Santa Claus pin. Interesting. We're dressed kind of similar. Very similarly. What's that about? I don't know, but Phyllis has a full Christmas blouse and vest. I love her Christmas vest. My sister's a school teacher, and she does that.
而且我们都戴着某种版本的圣诞老人胸针。有意思。我们穿得有点像。非常像。这是怎么回事？我不知道，但菲利斯穿着一件全套的圣诞衬衫和马甲。我喜欢她的圣诞马甲。我妹妹是个学校老师，她就那样穿。
Like at Christmas time, she wears all these Christmas sweaters and vests. You know I love this stuff. I've got all of it. My mom, back in St. Louis, Missouri, every year she goes to the local art fairs and craft fairs, and she sends me Christmas hoodies, Christmas vests, Christmas pajamas, Christmas everything.
比如在圣诞节的时候，她会穿所有这些圣诞毛衣和马甲。你知道我喜欢这些东西。我全都有。我妈妈在密苏里州圣路易斯，她每年都会去当地的艺术集市和工艺品集市，给我寄圣诞连帽衫、圣诞马甲、圣诞睡衣、圣诞所有东西。
I mean, those earrings could have been yours, because you've come to my house at Christmas, and you always have on Christmas jewelry. I'll tell you right now, I would never show up at a Christmas party, and only Christmas earrings and Christmas pin. I know. I mean, that is, I know.
我的意思是，那些耳环本来可以是你的，因为你圣诞节来过我家，你总是戴着圣诞首饰。我直说吧，我绝不会只戴着圣诞耳环和圣诞胸针就去参加圣诞派对。我知道。我是说，那是，我知道。
I go all out. You go all out. Oh, Oscar has a Christmas tie. Oscar has a Christmas tie. Stanley has a red tie, so I guess that's his attempt. Very Stanley. That's as far as he would go. I'm actually surprised he went that far.
我全力以赴。你全力以赴。哦，奥斯卡系了一条圣诞领带。奥斯卡系了一条圣诞领带。斯坦利系了一条红领带，所以我想这就是他的尝试了。非常斯坦利。这就是他能做到的极限了。我其实很惊讶他做到了这一步。
No, no. For Stanley. I know. Also, Meredith has a crazy Christmas sweater. Yeah, see, if it were me, I would be Meredith or Phyllis showing up to your party. Full outfit. I know.
不，不。对斯坦利来说。我知道。还有，梅雷迪思有一件疯狂的圣诞毛衣。对，你看，如果是我，我就会像梅雷迪思或菲利斯那样去参加你的派对。全套服装。我知道。
I've seen how you've come to my party. I love it. All right, so in this scene that's coming up, Jim reveals that he got Pam in Secret Santa. He does. Can I? Listen, Jim fans, you're probably not going to like me for saying this.
我知道你是怎么来我的派对的。我很喜欢。好吧，所以在接下来的这个场景中，吉姆透露他在秘密圣诞老人活动中抽到了帕姆。他确实抽到了。我能说吗？听着，吉姆的粉丝们，你们可能不会喜欢我这么说。
But at two minutes, two seconds, in his talking head, he says he wants, you know, he got Pam for Secret Santa. And he said, because Pam wants a teapot, so she can make tea at her desk. Yeah. And I wrote WTF. Who makes tea at their desk? She would go in the kitchen.
但在两分钟零两秒时，在他的单采镜头里，他说他想要，你知道的，他在秘密圣诞老人活动中抽到了帕姆。他说，因为帕姆想要一个茶壶，这样她就可以在座位上泡茶了。是的。我写下了 WTF。谁会在办公桌上泡茶？她会去厨房的。
What is she going to do? Go to the kitchen, put the hot water in the teapot, carry it back to her desk, pour herself a cup of tea at her desk. Exactly. She's going to carry that teapot from the kitchen. What part of this is confusing you? I think is ridiculous.
她要做什么？去厨房，把热水倒进茶壶里，端回办公桌，在办公桌给自己倒杯茶。没错。她要把那个茶壶从厨房端过来。这有什么让你困惑的？我觉得这太荒谬了。
OK, here's her other option. OK, she goes into the kitchen. Yeah. Oh, I see the breakdown. I see how your brain is tracking it and why it doesn't make sense. And also, because I know you and you just put the teabag right into the cup, which is a totally acceptable way
好吧，这是她的另一个选择。好吧，她去厨房。哦，我明白了问题的症结。我明白你的大脑是怎么想的了，以及为什么这说不通。而且，因为我了解你，你只会把茶包直接放进杯子里，这绝对是一种可以接受的方式
to make it. Some people let it seep. Steep. Steep. Steep. With a tea. Let it seep on in there. You leave it in your pot.
把它泡好。有些人让它浸泡。浸泡。浸泡。浸泡。用茶。让它就在那儿浸泡。你把它留在茶壶里。
That's right. I said that the scene could be called something else. What could it be called? Instead of what's inside the teapot, it could be called Jim's Got It Bad. Oh. Because he saved two sauce packets from a few years ago. Yeah.
没错。我说过这个场景可以叫别的名字。叫什么好呢？不用茶壶里装的东西，可以叫吉姆陷得很深。哦。因为他保存了两包几年前的酱料包。对。
That's someone who has got it really bad. OK. Yeah. Yeah. I feel like that could have been written a little differently where Jim could have said a couple of years ago, Pam did this thing with the hot sauce. And therefore, I am putting a packet of hot sauce in there.
这就是陷得很深的人。好吧。对。对。我觉得这一段如果换一种写法可能会有点不同，吉姆可以说几年前，帕姆用辣酱做了这件事。因此，我把一包辣酱放在那里。
The fact that he saved the two packets of hot sauce. For years. For years. Yeah. He loves you. He loves you. OK, go on. He definitely does.
他居然留着这两包辣酱。好几年。好几年。对。他爱你。他爱你。好吧，继续。他绝对是。
All right. Well, I do have a lot to say about the teapot. So first of all, Phil Shea offered me a variety of teapots before we started shooting in many colors. And I picked the teal. I love it. Yeah.
好吧。嗯，关于这个茶壶我确实有很多话要说。首先，在我们开拍之前，菲尔·谢伊提供了各种颜色供我选择的茶壶。我挑了青绿色。我太喜欢了。对。
I don't know. A little pop of color. The writers also said that picking what this gift would be, the fact that it would be a teapot, provided a major challenge. Because they needed a gift that could hide other gifts that was really personal and that would be very stressful when Dwight takes it away from Pam.
我不知道。增添了一点色彩。编剧们还说，挑选这个礼物会是什么，也就是茶壶，带来了一个重大挑战。因为他们需要一件既能藏着其他非常私人的礼物，又会在德怀特从帕姆那里抢走它时让人感到非常紧张的礼物。
It could only cost $20, and it had to be something that Dwight really wanted. And they said it was not easy. They spent a very long time. Because they knew plot-wise what had to happen, that Jim gives Pam a gift filled with secret treasures that Dwight also wants to have that costs under $20. It took them a very long time to come up with teapot.
它只能花20美元，而且必须是德怀特真正想要的东西。他们说这可不容易。他们花了很长时间。因为他们从剧情上知道接下来会发生什么，吉姆给帕姆一件装满秘密宝藏的礼物，而德怀特也想拥有，价格在20美元以下。他们花了很长时间才想出茶壶这个点子。
For that reason alone, OK, fine. Pam can make her tea at the counter. She can steal some tea at her desk. Because when Dwight puts it in his nose, I know that's later. But it's so perfect. It is. It's so perfect.
仅凭这一点，好吧，行。帕姆可以在柜台泡茶。她可以在办公桌上偷偷泡茶。因为当德怀特把它塞进鼻子时，我知道那是后面发生的事。但它太完美了。确实。太完美了。
I mean, they nailed it, right? They nailed it. And now this teapot is famous. I mean, all the time, people are using this teapot idea to propose to their loved ones. I see it all the time. And my Instagram, people are tagging me. It's always charming to me.
我的意思是，他们成功了，对吧？他们成功了。现在这个茶壶出名了。我是说，一直以来，人们都在用这个茶壶的想法向爱人求婚。我经常看到。在我的Instagram上，人们在标记我。这对我来说总是很有魅力。
It's always so sweet. It is very thoughtful. So we mentioned the things that he's putting into the teapot. Here's a fan question. Taylor Rilling said, what is the significance of the pencil that Jim puts in the teapot? Yeah, he said that the story is too long. So we have a deleted scene.
总是那么甜蜜。非常体贴。所以我们提到了他塞进茶壶里的东西。这里有一个粉丝提问。泰勒·里林说，吉姆放进茶壶里的铅笔有什么意义？对，他说这个故事太长了。所以我们有一个被删减的片段。
And I remember shooting it. What Pam says when she picks up the pencil is she says, oh my gosh, this is the pencil I threw at you during mini-golf. What? When did Jim and Pam go play mini-golf? Maybe the whole office went and played mini-golf. That seems like something Michael Scott would be like, we're going to play mini-golf, and we're
我记得拍摄情景。帕姆拿起铅笔时说的是，哦天哪，这支铅笔是我在迷你高尔夫球场扔向你的！什么？吉姆和帕姆什么时候去打过迷你高尔夫？也许整个办公室都去打迷你高尔夫了。这听起来像是迈克尔·斯科特会做的事，比如，我们要去打迷你高尔夫，而且我们
going to raise money for my neighbors, whatever. That's all I can think of is that there was some office outing where they went and played mini-golf, and I guess Pam got all feisty and threw a pencil at him, and he saved it. So that's where the pencil is. And then, of course, he puts a card in the box, and he says, because Christmas time is the time
要为我的邻居筹款，诸如此类。我能想到的就是有一次办公室集体出游，他们去打迷你高尔夫，我猜帕姆当时很争强好胜，朝他扔了一支铅笔，而他把它留作了纪念。所以铅笔的来历就是这样。然后，当然，他在盒子里放了一张卡片，他说，因为圣诞节是
to tell people how you feel. Oh, yeah, that's so loaded. I have PPC next. Let's hit some PPC, the party planning committee. You know, Mike Scherr also wrote the PPC and the Alliance. I think he likes the PPC. He definitely likes the PPC, and their weird sort of power struggle.
向人们表达你内心感受的时刻。哦，是的，这话太意味深长了。接下来我要说PPC。我们来聊聊PPC，也就是派对策划委员会。你知道，迈克·舒尔也写了PPC和同盟。我想他很喜欢PPC。他绝对喜欢PPC，以及他们之间那种奇怪的权力争夺。
He loves it. Well, in this scene, we find out that Ryan has been drafted into the PPC. I can't believe that. I remember that. I can't believe that Angela Martin would recruit him, except that maybe she needed help, like someone setting up things and moving things.
他太喜欢了。嗯，在这个场景中，我们发现瑞安被征召加入了PPC。我简直不敢相信。我记得那个。我简直不敢相信安吉拉·马丁会招募他，除非她可能需要人帮忙，比如有人来布置和搬运东西。
Well, the Christmas party is a big one. It's a big one. Yeah. But also, I noticed that Meredith is in there. Yeah. No, it's all hands on deck. She probably has a bigger crew than just her core crew. Well, that's when Michael enters in his Santa beard.
嗯，圣诞派对可是一场大派对。是一场大派对。对。不过我也注意到梅雷迪思也在里面。对。不，所有人都要出动。她手下的人可能不仅仅是她的核心团队。嗯，就在这时，迈克尔戴着圣诞老人胡子登场了。
He throws down some cash because he wants a bigger, better party. And he reveals he has a digital camera, and he will be taking photos. Yeah, and he's going to put them in the newsletter. Most embarrassing one wins. Yes. I want you guys to know, when Steve came behind Phyllis
他扔下了一些现金，因为他想要一个更大、更好的派对。并且他透露他有一台数码相机，他会拍照。对，他要把照片放进时事通讯里。最尴尬的一个获胜。是的。我想让你们知道，当史蒂夫走到菲利斯
and I, and he was like, I want people making out. And he shoved her heads together and was like, blah, blah, blah. That was an improv. That was improv. Yeah. Phyllis and I didn't know that was coming. He just did it in the moment.
和我身后时，他说，我想看到人们热吻。接着他把我们的头推到一起，说，啦啦啦。那是即兴发挥。那是即兴发挥。对。菲利斯和我事先都不知道。他当时就那么做了。
I was really proud that neither of us started laughing. I was so proud of myself, because there were a few times in that scene, I almost broke, and I was really fighting it. Oh, it's also in this scene, Angela, that it's revealed that Phyllis was in charge of getting the lights for the Christmas tree. And she said she got the little ones. Yeah, and you have a reaction to that?
我很自豪我们俩谁都没有笑出来。我为自己感到骄傲，因为那个场景中有好几次，我差点笑场，我一直在极力克制。哦，也是在这个场景中，安吉拉，大家发现菲利斯负责采购圣诞树的彩灯。她说她买的是小串的那种。对，你对此有什么反应？
Well, that's not going to go over well later. That is not going to go over. So like I said, I listened to the DVD commentary of this. And Mike was really good on the commentary at breaking down some of his goals for the episode. And his goal for the episode was that Angela would get more and more and more stressed out every scene that we see her.
嗯，这后来可讨不了好。这绝对讨不了好。所以就像我说的，我听了这集的DVD评论音轨。迈克在评论中非常擅长剖析他在这一集中的一些目标。他这一集的目标是，我们在每一个镜头中看到的安吉拉，都会变得越来越焦虑。
And I think you can track that. Like as I was watching it again, I can totally see that. I have five note cards called Angela's Pistofness that I'm going to start with time code soon. Before we get into all that, I do have to point out, because I was texting with Kim Ferry, who did my hair for nine years on the office last night. This is the Angela hair braid.
我想你可以注意到这一点。就像我再次观看时，我完全能看出来。我有五张写着“安吉拉的暴躁”的便签，我很快就会按时间轴开始讲。在我们谈到所有这些之前，我必须指出来，因为昨晚我一直在跟金·费里发短信，她在《办公室》剧组为我做九年的头发。这就是安吉拉的发辫。
That is my actual hair that she had me bend over and braid. And of course, my character would want to wear it to the Christmas party. Of course. I feel like this was her special braid. For special occasions. For special occasions. And while we're talking PPC guys, I have to say,
那是我真正的头发，她让我弯下腰编的。当然，我的角色会想在圣诞派对上戴着它。当然。我觉得这是她的专属发辫。为了特殊场合。为了特殊场合。在我们讨论PPC的时候，我不得不说，
Pam would probably irk me too on this committee. What? I mean, at four minutes, 25 seconds, Angela is trying to put a tablecloth on this table. Pam is just staring at her, doing nothing, not trying to grab for the tablecloth, help her spread it out, anything. And Angela just looks at her and is just like,
在这个委员会里，帕姆可能也会让我觉得很烦。什么？我是说，在4分25秒的时候，安吉拉正试图往这张桌子上铺桌布。帕姆就只是盯着她，什么也不做，既不伸手去拿桌布，也不帮她把桌布铺开，什么都不做。然后安吉拉看着她，就像是在说，
will you help me? When I saw that scene, I found it so satisfying. It's her little bit of defiance against your just crazy controlling. Yes, yes, just your everything that's coming at her. And I told you, I go back and I read my journals. And I had written, and I also have these old blogs. And I had written in one of my old blogs
你肯帮帮我吗？当我看到那个场景时，我感到非常满足。这是她对你那种疯狂控制欲的一点小小反抗。对，对，就是对她迎面而来的你的一切的反抗。我跟你说过，我回去读了我的日记。我当时写过，我还留着这些旧博客。我在其中一篇旧博客里写过
that filming the scene where I don't help you put the tablecloth on was one of my favorites of the whole episode. It's such like passive aggressive defiance. I loved it. I loved it. Well, Jenna, I went and found my MySpace blogs. So they're not online anymore.
拍摄我不帮你铺桌布的那场戏，是整集中我最喜欢的戏之一。这简直是一种被动的攻击性反抗。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。好吧，珍娜，我去找到了我的MySpace博客。所以它们现在已经不在网上了。
I don't know why, but I guess I had printed them out at some point. Smart. So now I'm going to start going to them for each episode. And I did for this one, but I'll save it for a bit. Because it happens later in the episode. OK, great. Fan question from small actor in a p-coat.
Who kept the camera with all of the pictures that Michael took? NBC. Yeah, they were property of NBC. And they had them up on their website for a while. But guess what? You can still find them. And Jenna and I were texting last night. We both found them over at officetally.com.
Yeah, so you can see all those pictures that he was really taking pictures. Yeah, and they're really not centered. And people's heads are cut off. It's as if he just went around clicking away. But there's some real gems in there. I know. Six minutes, 54 seconds.
Michael really, really shows what he thinks about Christmas, which is a gift, should say. I love you this mini-dollar's worth. Yeah. Oh, this is not going to go well. Well, speaking of gifts, we have a scene where Toby reveals what he got Angela in Secret Santa. And it is the jazz baby poster.
Yeah, I have that poster, guys. You have it? That was one of my questions from Chris Cordova. He wants to know, did you keep the baby poster? Well, there was about 20 of them. They had made a bunch. One hung by my desk for years. Yes, yeah.
So we got to see it every day. And I have one. It's rolled up in a little poster thingy. Now, do you know the story behind that picture? Because I traded some text messages with Phil Shea. So Phil Shea had to make that poster. He did not buy that poster. He put out a casting call for babies.
And two babies were cast, baby actors. He said it was really hard to find tiny jazz instruments. He said that was really difficult. In fact, he said Amazon didn't exist back then. You couldn't just Google baby jazz instrument. And they couldn't be fake looking. They couldn't be like blue and pink. So he did eventually find them at a place
called Hollywood Costumes. He was particularly proud of the tiny sunglasses that he found. This poster ends up coming back in conflict resolution. Like you said, it stayed up there. But then it comes back again. It comes back again. I would like to know the two babies that were in the poster.
Oh, guys. Where are they today? If you are a baby from the baby jazz poster, will you please write to us at officeladiesatearwolf.com? One thing about that baby jazz poster, I remember Mike Schur telling me that they thought it was really funny that Angela would really enjoy babies dressed as adults.
OK, where are we? Well, we're talking about the gifts. And Mike Schur actually said that the gifts were incredibly hard to manage. Because they start off as Secret Santa, so everybody had a person that they bought a specific gift for, and then you had to track the gifts as they went around in the Yankee swap.
He actually, in the script of this episode, there is a whole page where he lists the gifts. Who bought who what? And he did this for Veda, our script supervisor. We haven't really talked about her, but Veda's job is to sit and watch every take that is filmed and make notes about everything that happens continuity-wise.
So I mean, really specific. So if in a scene, you take a drink of your tea on a certain line and then scratch your nose on another one, Veda writes it down so that you do it the same every time for editing purposes. Yeah, Veda would come up to us and say, Angela, you were holding that pen in your left hand in the first take. And in the second take, you picked it up
and held it in your right hand. So that's not going to match. So you need to pick which hand you're going to hold that pen in and do it in every take the same way. Yeah, because otherwise, when you edit it together, the pen is magically bouncing from hand to hand. So Mike was really worried about Veda in this episode. And so he made this list just for Veda.
And I have it from the script. Yay, oh, fantastic. OK, so this is what everyone was intended to give. And we got a lot of fan questions about this. A lot of people wrote in and said, eventually Michael's going to get the paintball lessons from Dwight, but they're like, who did Dwight intend that to go to? So I have all the answers right here.
You ready? Yeah. OK. Dwight got Phyllis, the paintball lessons, and the pellets. That was his gift to Phyllis. Phyllis made Michael an oven mitt. Michael got Ryan an iPod. Ryan got Toby a book of short stories by George Saunders,
who happens to be one of Mike Scher's favorite writers. Toby got Angela the baby poster. Angela bought Stanley a picture frame. Stanley got Kelly a name plate. Kelly got Oscar a shower radio. Oscar got Creed a shamrock key chain. Creed got Jim one of his own shirts. Jim got Pam the teapot.
And this is something that got cut out. Pam made Meredith a drawing of the office. I read about that online. Yeah, and there was this big thing. It's in the deleted scenes. This is something I have to tell you. I got a DVD player for Christmas. What?
My husband got me a DVD player, so I got the CDs. He bought me the CD set, and I got a DVD player. And last night, I got to watch all the deleted scenes. Oh, Angela, you must be so happy. I was so happy, and there's so many. Oh, yeah. There's so many. For the Christmas episode, you guys,
there are so many great deleted scenes. I don't want to get us off topic here, but they're in the deleted scenes. Meredith opens up her painting. That is from Pam, and it's a drawing of the office. Well, there's a big backstory here. Again, with Phil, I don't do Pam's drawings. People ask me that all the time.
I'm not an artist. I mean, we've talked about this, or have we, that I do cartoons. I do cartooning. She's very good at cartooning, and I have a few that you've drawn that I've saved. I think you're fantastic. Well, I love my little expressive cartoons,
but I needed Pam and wanted Pam to be a better artist than I am. So there is a young art student that does all of Pam's drawings. They went out to a bunch of people, like 12 different artists, to turn in samples to be the artist behind Pam, and they picked a young woman. Now, Jenna, I read, and you can tell me if this is true, I read that the first painting that they had for this episode to give to Meredith from Pam, that they had one of our set
art people, who was a man, do it, and when they looked at it, it looked too masculine, and so then they went out to female artists to have a little bit of a softer touch. And there were something like 12 different artists who all submitted their work, and I wish I knew her name. Unfortunately, I don't, but maybe I can find that out and reveal that in a future episode. And then so finally, two more gifts.
Meredith got Dwight, some shot glasses from Cancun, and Kevin got himself a foot bath. Guys, around five minutes, 55 seconds, there is a scene where Michael is talking to Jim at Jim's desk. This is when he reveals that he got Ryan for Secret Santa. And I just want to say, you see a ton of background action. Angela, you're walking from reception. Over Steve's shoulder, you see Toby and Mindy talking.
Yeah. They are 100% not in character. Not in character at all. I saw that, too. I was like, they're just talking about probably something in the writer's room or a story pitch, or they're just having a conversation. Yeah, I mean, Paul is just being Paul.
If anyone's curious, the difference between Toby and Paul, go to five minutes, 55 seconds. And you can see Paul and Mindy having a conversation in the background. Yeah, exactly. Tree lighting. OK, I have been waiting for this moment. The Christmas tree lighting, this
starts the beginning of everyone happy Angela pissed. So this Christmas tree, the top of it has been hacked off by Kevin. It is covered in so much tinsel. Yeah. So much tinsel. It has a smattering of just blue and red ball ornaments. It's just not their best effort.
And then it has the tiniest of tiny white lights, thanks to Phyllis. So Dwight makes a big deal of it. He takes the outlet, the plug, what do you call it? The plug? The plug. He takes the plug from Stanley. He wants to plug it in.
He's like, just like Rockefeller Center. And everyone gathers around. And it's like, brrr, brrr. And Phyllis is like, I'm sorry. And it's six minutes, 38 seconds. You see my first pissed-off face. Dang it, Phyllis. It's also one of those moments where I feel like Angela is
like, I knew it. I knew it. I knew I couldn't trust her to do these lights. Why do I even have her do anything? Why do you have anyone do anything? Yeah. You can't let anyone do anything. These people are worthless.
Exactly. You know, that Christmas tree light thing is based on a real thing from Mike Sharer's life? I know. He said that when Hannah's wife got their first tree in New York, he bought a bunch of small lights for the tree. And he wrapped them around. And when he plugged it in, you couldn't really see them.
I love that. I love when writers work those little moments from their real life into the show. I thought, speaking about people who are acting like themselves instead of their characters, I thought Jim's talking head about Creed's gift is so John. It is John. That is John right there.
Yeah. The delivery, the smile, all of it. And then, of course, Creed's talking head made me laugh so hard. Creed is very funny in this episode. I mean, everybody has some great moments. But Creed cracked me up a bunch in this episode. So now Secret Santa is starting.
Yep. And everyone is gathered around in some office chairs. And I want to say truly, I know we were joking about Charles McDougal, but the amount of energy and movement that he uses the camera to give this scene of people sitting in a circle, I mean, it is impressive from a directorial standpoint.
I think, like, I don't want to be crazy, but I think, like, film students should study this portion of the episode. Because I'm imagining myself trying to film a group of people sitting in a circle doing a gift exchange. And it would not look nearly this dynamic. It's really, really impressive directing.
No, he's great. He is really great. OK, so we're starting the Secret Santa, and Pam opens Jim's teapot. She loves it. But Dwight moves things along so quickly that she doesn't have time to look inside or notice the card that's in the box.
Yeah. Dwight wants no chitty chat between gifts. He's like, go, go, go, go, go. He's me coming in today. He is. He's like, save it for the mic. So he's moving things along. So it's Pam.
And then the next one. We find out that Michael buys Ryan a video iPod that costs $400. You guys, this was not product placement. It was not. So many people wanted to know. Yeah. We were not paid.
It was just sort of a really cool topical gift at the time. Yeah. And they were trying to think of a gift that would sort of be a showstopper that Michael would think was very impressive that everyone would want. So this was coincidence. We weren't paid to use it. So I read that that.
Well, here's the something. A ton of people wanted to know who kept it at the end. Nobody. We weren't allowed to keep any of the stuff. It all goes into a giant warehouse and it gets labeled for the episode for props. Because if for some reason we have to go back and reshoot something, they take it off the shelf and they bring it back in.
That's true. I don't know what happens after it's been in the warehouse for a while, but it just goes to prop house storage. I feel like it's still in a box labeled the office Christmas party. It probably is. There was a fan question from beard up, beard down. Was the iPod sponsored by Apple?
It wasn't. We said it was not. It's just a total coincidence. But there's more coincidence. So the week after this episode aired, Apple revealed that you could now download episodes of the office onto these video iPods. Again, this was not planned.
And then the office became the number one downloaded show on iTunes. Yes. The number one downloaded show. I remember Rain Wilson turned to me and said, I think we're going to make it. I think we're going to. This was the first moment.
It felt like the tide was turning for us and that we might not get canceled. All right. So next up, Michael gets his gift. The oven mitt knitted by Phyllis. Now everyone had a $20 limit, you guys. That's why this iPod really shakes everything up, because he spent $400.
Yes. Yes. And he has his line where he says, I only, he says, out in the hallway, he's holding the mitt. And he says, do you know what this says? This says, I only care about you, a homemade oven mitts worth. He is such a child. He is such a bratty kid in this episode.
Oh my gosh. Well, we had a fan question from Chelsea, Raccoza, and Amanda, and many others actually, who actually knitted the oven mitt? Well, I asked Phyllis, she does not knit in real life. Although she told me that she knitted a scarf for her mom a couple of years ago, but she said that's it. She didn't, oh, just one scarf.
I want you guys to know, you know how we talk about what was at everyone's desk? So at Phyllis' desk, like sitting on the floor, sort of next to her desk for so many years, was a whole knitting basket. Do you remember? I do remember that. It had all the yarn and the knitting needles,
and it sat there as if her character would ever do anything with it. But it was established there, and it sat there. Well, Phil Shea told me he found a woman at a knitting store in Valley Village, California, and she knitted the oven mitt. Again, oven mitt knitter, if you're listening, please write us at officeladiesatearwolf.com, and we'll give you a shout out.
Yeah. Knitted the famous mitt. I thought it looked like a great oven mitt, and it had like the little like a. Like the Teflon. Teflon anythingy on the one side. Yeah. So Ryan gets the iPod, and at eight minutes, 24 seconds,
is the next phase of Angela Pistofness. OK. You see my face at the fact that Michael spent $400 when the limit was 20, all of my instructions. I'm sure I sent out an email about Secret Santa and the rules. So one, Phyllis has ignored my request for bigger lights and got the tiny lights.
Now two, Michael has spent $400 instead of their grade upon $20. So we're ramping up. She's getting ticked off. I have no doubt that you sent a very detailed email about this to everyone with a follow up reminder. Which is why Kevin does not come forward when he gets himself, because he would have had to tell me.
He would have. Yeah. You know what, I really relate to Angela on so many levels. Listen, I really do. There's on some levels, you're way more Angela than I am. Oh yeah. I mean, I would have generated two, three, four very detailed emails about the party, the plans.
If I assigned someone to do lights for the tree and that's what I got, I would feel so pissed and let down. If people went over the $20 budget, you would have been furious. Furious. Because you would have been like, what's the point? Why even have that number? Is Angela wrong?
No, I don't think she's wrong. She's just, you know, why is no one helping her? She's a by the book person. Why can't people follow the rules? I agree. So at nine minutes, 39 seconds, she gets pissed off on a whole new level because, as you were saying, this is when Michael is really ticked off
that he got the oven mitt and he switches the party. No more secret, Santa. He says, now we're doing Yankee Swap. Yes. Yankee Swap slash white elephant slash, what was the other one he said? Nasty Christmas. Nasty Christmas.
You know, there was actually a little debate about what do you call it? And people were like, well, we call it white elephant. And someone else was like, we call it Yankee Swap. And I feel like the writers took that and put it in the episode. Yeah, I know it as Yankee Swap. What do you know about it? I knew it as white elephant.
Yeah. I think it's good they did that. They covered everybody. They covered everybody. But when I threw my Christmas party, I called it Yankee Swap just because I loved it so much. You know, here's something that I heard in the commentary, Angela, since we're
talking about your character. I guess that you had a talking head in the fire. I watched it because I have a DVD player now. Where you cried. Yes, in the deleted scenes. Well, Mike said that the writer's room was so impressed with your performance and that talking head that they put a card on the wall that was Angela cries.
And they wanted to find an episode where you could cry a bunch. And this was it. Mike sure told me he said, I love to see your character cry. He said she's so pulled together that when you sort of fall apart, it's like really sort of oddly pleasing. Oh, I love it. I love it. So yes, at 9 minutes, 51 seconds, I have a talking head.
And my character is really upset because she feels like Michael should have talked to the PPC first. Yeah, well, they should have. And then she breaks down. So she is really starting to spiral. And then when we cut back to the scene, she's still sobbing. I mean, she's not sobbing, but she's still crying.
She's sullen. She's very sullen. OK, you know this famous line. Yankee swap. Yeah. From Michael. All right, Mike sure. That's a written line.
That wasn't improvised. That Steve would say Yankee swap. And Mike wrote in the script in parentheses crazy voice. And he was like, I know Steve will do something great with that. And that was Steve's take on that because they would do that. They would sometimes put little pieces of direction in the script for us. And then we'd have to interpret it.
Yeah. Guys, did you notice in this episode, it is snowing outside. I loved this touch. I love that they kept cutting to the windows and there'd be snow. Do you remember how much fun it was to have the snow? We were so tickled by the snow. So excited. You guys remember we mostly just filmed inside
and we never even saw outside or what was happening outside. And so the fact that we had this extra element happening was so fun. We really did film inside in a windowless warehouse. All the windows were fake. They just had backdrops behind them. So to see actual sunshine or snow or air was really exciting to us. I have a ton of facts about the snow.
I don't know if anyone else will find it interesting. But I had written all about it in one of my blogs slash journals. I'm living for this. I can't wait to hear about it. I do have to pee. Oh, do you want me to give you some snow facts when we come back from the break? I mean, can I go?
You should be on an empty bladder when I lay these awesome facts on you. You don't tell me or my bladder what we're doing. Well, what do you want? Do you want full bladder snow facts or empty bladder snow facts? I want empty bladder snow facts. All right, that's what I'm saying. Oh, I thought you were telling me
that I had to not drink any more water or tea. When we go on a road trip, my husband will be like, can you not get a nice tea? OK, clearly you're projecting some other thing on me. Because I said I thought you should empty your bladder for the snow facts she's leaving. First, you push away from the mic to eat your snack. This is for you, Jenna.
So disgusting. Those are high-nut Cheerios. Oh, God. MUSIC Thank you for letting me have my bathroom break. I want to hear all about your snow. All right, I hope this isn't anticlimactic for people. But the company that came to make the snow
is called Snow Business. I love that. Snow business. Snow business. I remembered. I remembered that. It's so tickled me. OK, so here's how it works with fake snow.
There's a guy from Snow Business. He shows up. Now, the snow that falls from the sky is different from the ground cover snow. The snow on the ground is snow. The snow that falls from the sky, I know because it falls on my character at the end. And it is not snow.
It's not snow. It's soap. Yes, you can get a choice. You can get a choice of cornstarch, plastic, or soap. And Greg watched a demonstration of all three, and he picked soap. Well, when by accident, a little piece of that might get in your mouth, it tastes like soap.
Because I shriek, and a piece of it went in my mouth. That's what she said. Yeah, yeah. OK. On the ground, though, it's real snow. And they bring this machine. And I don't know exactly how it works, but it's kind of like a wood chipper, but in reverse.
It looks like something out of a Dr. Seuss book. It does. It really does. And it really blows snow. I guess that's what it looks like. It looks like a snowblower, but it generates snow. And then it just blows it all over the ground, all over the cars, and all that stuff.
But guys, remember, this is like, we're shooting this in October in Los Angeles, and it's hot in October. It stays warm here. In the daytime, it's still in the mid-80s, 90s. But it was night, and so we had a little bit of time with it. I mean, it was still warm out. Yeah, it was probably in the high 60s.
Yeah, that sounds about right. All right. Yes, we were very excited to have snow. And, Jenna, we're. Did you like my snow facts? I feel a little vulnerable about them now, because we set them up so much. I mean, there was like a break, and in my head about it.
I like your snow facts. Snow business. That's cute. I think snow business is really cute. All right, but let's go back to the gift exchange. This is when Kelly gets Angela's poster, but Angela, you do get to take it back. OK, here's the thing.
I wrote in my MySpace blog about this moment. And I wrote that it was one of the hardest things for us to get through as a cast, that the first time Mindy unrolls the poster and looks at it, and we all see it, we all, every person, lost it. Because it's so ridiculous. It's so ridiculous. We had not seen it.
It was an actual surprise to us while we were filming. And we all lost it. I had that, in fact, it was particularly hard on rain for some reason, and that in one take, he broke three times because he could not get through it. I can't believe that Mindy was tasked with having to unroll that poster. How did we ever get a shot of her not laughing?
I don't know, but we were cracking up. There's a little detail in that scene that made me laugh when I rewatched it, which is how you just very subtly swat the oven midway on your way to getting the poster. That was all me. Thank you very much. I loved it.
It was such a good detail. I loved it. Well, in tracking the oven mid, Meredith eventually takes the oven mid. But you know, Michael has to then call her a sucker and say that he wanted her to take it, and it was reverse psychology when he said he wanted to keep it. I love that he decided that he needed
to break down reverse psychology to all of us, because I don't know if you've heard of it. This is a pretty cool thing. Michael, you're such an idiot. Do you remember how Phyllis cried during that scene? Yeah, she stayed in that sad place. She cried for a half hour, and in between takes of that, where she had to be crying.
She didn't want any of us to talk to her. And Kate and I tried to go up and give her a hug. She didn't want it. She was in this actor zone. It's so hard to do. It's so hard to do. I know exactly where she was, but I just remember being really worried for her,
because when you see Phyllis cry, it is, ugh. You don't want to see Phyllis cry, because it breaks every part of you open. I mean, she had to stay sad, and it is really hard, especially sitting in this circle with people cracking up about a baby poster. But you've got to stay sad. Yes.
It's hard. It's really hard. It's very difficult. Well, here's the thing. Michael just gets progressively meaner. He calls Meredith a sucker, and then Dwight, he opens the paintball, and he's like, ugh. How is this better than an iPod?
And this moment kind of broke my heart, too, when Dwight goes, I never said it was better. Wait, I have an Angela pissed off in this moment. OK, go. At 13 minutes, 58 seconds, look at my face. I wrote it in all caps. So Michael has just called Meredith a sucker, because she got the lame oven mitt, and Phyllis storms out.
She was completely heartbroken now, and the party is falling apart, and the look on my face is just sheer rage. Now, are we at the top of your rage now? No. Oh, no. Well, I mean, I know we've still got the parking lot, but. No.
Oh, no. There's a moment coming, and you'll know it. It's the there's a one-two punch coming at the end for my anger. But yeah. All right, so people are making trades, and feelings are getting hurt. Yeah.
And Pam does not go back and get the teapot. She gets the iPod. She does. When it's Pam's turn to pick again, she picks the iPod instead of the teapot, and Jim is so hurt. He's so hurt. And I watched this, and I was like, come on, Pam.
But then Pam doesn't know what all is in the teapot. She doesn't. And that's what sort of justified it for me. She's just like, this is an iPod. This iPod has completely hijacked this whole fun party and gift exchange, because everybody who's sitting in the seat is just thinking about trying to get this iPod.
And so is Pam. Unfortunately, I think she kind of forgot about the teapot. So it was her time to pick. She was just like, iPod. But she also doesn't know what's in the teapot. She doesn't. She doesn't know how high the stakes are for Jim. No.
She doesn't. I think it's kind of an innocent moment, honestly. And Michael has ruined all of this because the gifts were specific for people. I mean, Ryan gets a placard that says Kelly. He gets a desk, whatever, name plate. These were not meant to be Yankee swap gifts. They were not.
They were meant for certain people. Well, at this point, the party has completely broken down. And Michael goes to the liquor store. Now, I want to point out a few things. I know what you're going to point out. Because, lady, I have the DVDs now. So go. Do it.
Do you know what I'm going to say? Is it about the attendant at the liquor store? I have one thing to say about him. But I just thought I wanted to point out that it's also snowing outside the window of the liquor store. Yeah. They made it snow there, too. I don't know.
Nice detail. Nice touch. Good continuity. Vada was on it. Well, I read that our writers found out in Pennsylvania that if you work at a liquor store, you have to wear a tie. Yes. And so that was part of this character description,
is that he had to have on a tie. Isn't that great? And I thought the actor, his name is Ryan Martin, did a fantastic job. He just really takes in all of that vodka and is just. 15 bottles. 15 bottles. Craziness.
OK, so then we go back to the party. Michael brings all this vodka back into the party, and it's 16, 10 minutes. This is the next phase of Angela's spiral. Oh, say it. So Michael has vodka. And she's like, what are you doing? There's no alcohol at the party.
You know, Angela speaks up and Toby speaks up. No one else cares. But now she's like. Toby speaks up. I missed that. Yeah, Toby's like, Michael, we really shouldn't have. And he goes, just shut it, Toby. It's a party.
But then later, I feel like Toby brings Todd Packer a drink. Well, no, it's all, like, all that's off at this point. And you have to remember that Michael told the party planning committee that he wanted this Christmas party to be like, and I quote, a Playboy Mansion party. Yeah. That was his hope. That's his goal.
That's his goal. So but yeah, Angela is now super ticked because now there's alcohol. I'm surprised her whole head didn't explode. Well, it's about to because the next two are what set it into motion. Oh, boy. Well, now we have the scene where
Jim is trying to get the teapot back from Dwight. Jim offers to trade him the shamrock key chain. And he says, come on, it'll be good luck. And that's when Dwight has his line, a real man makes his own luck, Billy Zane, Titanic, and Angela. You made the entire cast t-shirts with that quote on them. And I still have mine. Oh my gosh, you do.
I do. It's a gray, long-sleeved t-shirt. Yes, from black writing. Just a quote across it. Yeah. So I had a friend at the time who had a t-shirt press because she had a small business. And I loved this line.
我有。是一件灰色的长袖T恤。对，上面有黑色的字。上面就印了一句台词。对。当时我有个朋友有一台T恤印花机，因为她开了一家小店。我很喜欢这句台词。
So much. I thought it was hilarious of all people for Dwight to quote. It would be Billy Zane. Well, people were asking if we gave each other gifts. That was a gift. You gave that out. I think you actually gave that out at Christmas that year. I did.
非常喜欢。我觉得德怀特能引用这句台词简直太搞笑了。那个人应该是比利·赞恩。好吧，当时大家都在问我们有没有送彼此礼物。那就算是一份礼物。那是你送的。我想你当年圣诞节真的把那个送出去了。我送了。
And you gave everyone an ornament. Yes, I got that cast photo. And I had it printed on an ornament for everyone. Yep. Aw. The idea that Dwight wants to keep the teapot in order to wash out his nasal passages with green tea is based on something that Greg Daniels has actually done.
而且你给每个人都送了一个小饰品。是的，我拿到了那张演员合照。我把它印在小饰品上送给了每个人。对啊。啊。德怀特想要留着茶壶以便用绿茶冲洗鼻腔的这个情节，是根据格雷格·丹尼尔斯自己做过的事情改编的。
Like with a neti pot? Yeah, I mean, but I've never put green tea in a neti pot. I haven't either. I've only used the saline solution that is recommended. But I could see Greg reading about it and giving it a try. But rain, the way rain wasn't that scene. And then he like shoved that teapot into his nostril. Yeah.
就像用洗鼻壶那样？对，我的意思是，但我从来没有在洗鼻壶里放过绿茶。我也没有。我只用过推荐的生理盐水。但我能想象格雷格读到过这个然后去尝试了一下。但是雷恩，那个镜头里雷恩的方式。然后他把那个茶壶塞进自己的鼻孔里。对。
And just John's face's gym is just like, are you kidding me? That's who gets my teapot? Like, it's so perfect. He's so bummed. Now, when I watched this with Lee, Lee said he wondered how Dwight didn't find the note in the box or how Dwight didn't open up the teapot. I thought of all of those things.
而吉姆的表情就是，你在开玩笑吗？拿到我茶壶的人竟然是他？天哪，太绝了。他太沮丧了。现在，我和李一起看这一集时，李说他很好奇德怀特怎么没发现盒子里的纸条，或者德怀特怎么没打开茶壶看看。我想到了所有这些事情。
I thought Dwight now has the cassette and the sauce packet. I mean, so you have to sort of suspend belief, I guess, at that moment that he took those out and just shoved him aside like, hmm, what's this crap? And just sort of shoved him aside in the box? Well, also, I don't think Jim is trying to get the teapot back for Pam. I think he's just trying to get the teapot back for himself.
我想德怀特现在有了磁带和酱料包。我的意思是，你大概只能暂时停止怀疑，就当他在那一刻把这些东西拿出来，然后随手往旁边一扔，心想，嗯，这是什么破烂？就随手扔在盒子里了？嗯，还有，我觉得吉姆不是想把茶壶给潘要回来。我觉得他只是想把茶壶给自己要回来。
He's just going to keep it now. That's what I think the motivation is there, because Pam is over up at the desk with Roy looking through her new iPod. I think Jim just wants to get it back because I think there's things inside it that are embarrassing. Yes, exactly.
他现在打算把它留着了。我觉得这就是他当时的动机，因为潘正和罗伊一起站在办公桌旁，翻看她崭新的iPod。我觉得吉姆只是想把它要回来，因为我觉得里面有些东西很尴尬。是的，没准。
But he's going to trade the key chain, and he's just going to take that teapot home now. So Pam is up at reception and she's showing Roy her new iPod. He's now at the party. He wasn't there for Yankee Swap, but he's all excited because now he doesn't have to buy it for Pam for Christmas. He was going to buy her this iPod, he tells her, and now he doesn't have to or he's just
但他打算用钥匙链换，而且他现在要直接把那个茶壶带回家了。所以潘在接待处，她正在向罗伊展示她崭新的iPod。他现在也来参加派对了好吧。他刚才没来参加白象礼品交换，但他现在兴奋极了，因为他现在不用给潘买圣诞礼物了。他本来打算给她买这个iPod的，他告诉她，现在他不用买了，或者他只是
going to get her a sweater. Thanks, Roy. Now the party is like 15 bottles of vodka in. Todd Packer has showed up. Oh, yeah. It's getting crazy. Everyone's doing shots. Angela's fuming.
打算给她买一件毛衣。谢谢你，罗伊。现在派对大概已经喝掉了15瓶伏特加。托德·帕克也来了。哦，对。场面开始失控了。每个人都在干杯。安吉拉气炸了。
I am fuming, but the icing on the cake of my pissed offness is about to happen. Oh, say it. Michael shouts to the whole bullpen. He says, oh my gosh, yes, Ryan, the king of the party planning. Thank you to Ryan for this awesome party. And the camera pans to me, and I am livid. Ryan, the temp, the king of the party planning committee,
我在气头上，但让我怒火中烧的最后一击马上就要发生了。哦，快说吧。迈克尔朝整个大办公区大喊。他说，哦天哪，太棒了，雷恩，派对策划之王。感谢雷恩举办了这么棒的派对。镜头摇向了我，我气得脸都绿了。雷恩，这个临时工，派对策划委员会之王，
are you kidding me? Yeah. Oh, that's it. She is pissed. Oh, no. And it's only going to get worse. That's not even still the worst thing that's happened to Angela. Nope.
你在开玩笑吗？对。哦，就是这样。她气疯了。哦，不。而且情况只会变得更糟糕。这甚至还不是安吉拉遇到的最糟糕的事。才不是呢。
I had a headache by the end of this episode. You must have. You were just scowling and pushing anger out of your temples this whole episode. You know when Todd Packer shows up and he has that line, what's up, my nerds? My nerds? That was an improv, sort of.
这一集看下来我头都疼了。你肯定头疼。你整整这一集都在怒目圆睁，太阳穴都快气得冒烟了。你知道托德·帕克出现时他说那句台词，最近怎么样，我的书呆子们？我的书呆子们？那是即兴发挥，算是吧。
In the script, what was written was what's up, nerds. And he just gave it that extra special touch of what's up, my nerds. I know. Well, that's also Dave Keckner. I mean, I think even the line when he's like, pack or need a drinky. Yeah. The line was probably like, he was getting me a drink.
剧本里写的是，最近怎么样，书呆子们。而他特意加上了那句特别的话，最近怎么样，我的书呆子们。我知道。好吧，那也是戴夫·科克纳。我的意思是，我觉得甚至当他说，帕克需要喝一杯吗？这句话的时候。是的。那台词可能就像是，他要给我拿杯饮料。
Yeah. You know? He brought so much to that role. It was amazing. And well, you know when he has to lay down on the desk and get the silly string on him, like when he passes out? I remember shooting that. He had to lay there forever.
是的。你知道吗？他在那个角色里倾注了太多心血。太棒了。还有，你知道当他必须躺在办公桌上，身上被喷满彩带的时候，就像他晕倒的时候？我记得拍摄那个场景。他不得不在那儿躺好久。
So he laid down on those desks which were not comfortable, right? And then they silly stringed his head. And then we had all these scenes where that's what he's doing. Well, if he got up, all the stuff that he was decorated in would have fallen off. It would have been impossible to recreate. So he had to just lay there even when we were on a break. Even when we were on a break.
所以他躺在那些一点也不舒服的办公桌上，对吧？然后他们把彩带喷在他头上。接着我们拍了好几场戏，他都保持着这个姿势。好吧，如果他站起来，他身上那些装饰物就会掉下来。那就根本无法还原了。所以即使我们在休息时，他也必须躺在那儿。即使我们在休息时也是。
And he was such a trooper. Talk about a trooper. And I wrote in my MySpace blog that Kate and I, because Kate and I knew Dave from Improv Days. We had all like done improv shows together. That Kate and I walked over and talked to him while he had to lay on the back. And we just sort of like caught up
而且他真的太配合了。说到配合。我在我的MySpace博客里写过，凯特和我，因为凯特和我从即兴表演时期就认识戴夫了。我们以前一起做过即兴表演秀。凯特和我走过去跟他聊天，当时他还不得不躺在靠背上。我们就是那种叙了叙旧，
and that it was so fun to see him. But I want you guys to know, if you're wondering what Todd Packer looks like at 20 minutes, 19 seconds, to really paint a picture here. Yeah. He's laying on his back kind of across a desk area, partition, right in the middle of the room. He has blue silly string on his head.
而且见到他真的很开心。但我想要让大家知道，如果你想知道在20分19秒时托德·帕克是什么样子，我来给大家描绘一下画面。对。他仰面躺在一个办公桌区域的隔板上，就在房间的正中央。他头上戴着蓝色的彩带。
Christmas lights around his torso. Christmas garland around his torso. Dwight's desk name plate on his stomach. And there's like a red empty solo cup kind of just like in his like the crook of his arm. And he had to lay like that with all those things on top of him. He passes out so quickly.
他的躯干上缠着圣诞彩灯。他的躯干上缠着圣诞花环。德怀特的桌上名牌放在他的肚子上。还有一个红色的空塑料红杯，就卡在他的手臂弯里。他不得不那样躺着，身上压着所有这些东西。他晕得太快了。
You have to imagine he showed up already half drunk. You know he did. You know he did. You know he did. OK, guys. So now we have the scene where Pam reveals to Jim that she got her teapot back. She trades Dwight the iPod for the teapot.
你一定得想象他出现的时候就已经半醉了。你知道他绝对喝了。你知道他绝对喝了。你知道他绝对喝了。好了，各位。现在我们来到这个场景：潘向吉姆坦白她把茶壶要回来了。她用iPod跟德怀特换回了茶壶。
And now she's going to look inside and find all the items. And it's very charming and sweet. And she is so delighted. But in this moment, Jim secretly steals the note back and puts it in his pocket. I know. He lost his courage. He did.
现在她要往里面看并找出所有的物品。这非常迷人且甜蜜，她高兴极了。但就在这时，吉姆偷偷把纸条拿了回来，放进了自己的口袋。我知道。他认怂了。他确实怂了。
Now when we reached out to fans to ask them what they wanted to know about the Christmas episode, I would say that about 80% of the comments and emails we received were along the lines of what is in the teapot note. Because as you know, in this episode, Pam does not read it. It is not revealed. But then in season nine, there's a scene where Jim has the documentary film crew put together
现在，当我们联系粉丝询问他们想了解关于圣诞节这一集的什么内容时，我想说，我们收到的大约80%的评论和电子邮件内容都类似于：茶壶里的纸条上写了什么。因为正如你们所知，在这一集中，潘没有读它。它并没有被揭晓。但后来在第九季中，有一个场景是吉姆让纪录片摄制组把他们恋爱的素材剪辑在了一起。
footage of their romance. And he shows it to Pam. And Pam sees that there was a note that Jim steals back. And then he hands it to her. And she reads it. How brilliant is that? And you know who that is. That's Greg Daniels.
然后他把它放给潘看。潘看到里面有一张纸条被吉姆偷了回去。接着他把它递给了她。然后她读了它。这有多绝？而且你知道那是谁的主意吗。那是格雷格·丹尼尔斯。
Because he was such a master at beautiful callback moments. I love that. Well, from the time that Jim stole the note, it drove people crazy. They always wanted to know what had been written in the note. Would Pam ever get the note? For years and years, will he ever give her the note? Around the time of the wedding, people
因为他是营造绝美前后呼应的高手。我太喜欢了。好吧，自从吉姆偷走那纸条以来，这把大家迷得神魂颠倒。他们一直想知道纸条上到底写了什么。潘什么时候才能看到这张纸条？年复一年，他到底会不会把纸条给她？在婚礼前后，大家
wanted him to give it to her as a wedding gift. Greg saved it till the end. I'm going to say something that I've never said before. I also feel like I'm maybe going to cry. What? Wait. Wait. What?
都希望他能把它当作结婚礼物送给她。格雷格把它留到了最后。我要说一件我从来没有说过的事。我也觉得我可能要哭了。什么？等等。等等。什么？
Are you going to say what was in the note? Are you going to say what was in the note? Sort of. Because I don't know what was on that card. None of us do. I'm the only one who knows and John knows. Oh, my gosh, lady. In that episode in season nine, I believe Greg suggested
你是要说纸条里写了什么吗？你是要说纸条里写了什么吗？算是吧。因为我不知道那张卡片上写了什么。我们谁都不知道。只有我知道，约翰也知道。哦，天哪，蕾迪。在第九季的那集中，我相信格雷格建议
to John that he write a personal message from himself to me just saying what our time together on the office meant to him. Oh, Jenna. Because we were wrapping up filming. We were wrapping up the series. And we were all so emotional at that time, you know? We were all sort of saying goodbye in different ways.
约翰写一条他自己给我的私人信息，只表达我们在办公室一起共事的时光对他意味着什么。哦，珍娜。因为我们当时快要拍完了。我们正在为这个系列收官。而且我们当时都非常情绪化，你知道吗？我们都在用不同的方式告别。
We were. And so that was his goodbye. Very similar to when we filmed that scene with Steve, where I said goodbye to him at the airport. And Paul Feig told me, just run up and say goodbye to your friend, Steve. Jeff Blitz said the same thing to me when I was in the car with Oscar.
我们确实是。所以那是他的告别。这非常类似于我们和史蒂夫拍那个场景的时候，我在机场跟他告别。保罗·菲格告诉我，直接跑过去跟你的朋友史蒂夫告别。杰夫·布里茨跟我说的话也一样，当时我和奥斯卡坐在车里。
And I say I loved Dwight. He said, Angela, in this moment, express your love for the show and everyone, and if you couldn't have it in your life anymore. And I disintegrated. Yeah. So I'm on camera. And I open up this note that John's written me.
我说我爱德怀特。他说，安吉拉，在这个时刻，表达你对这部剧和所有人的爱，以及如果你生命中再也没有它了会怎样。然后我崩溃了。对。所以我在镜头前。我打开了约翰写给我的这张纸条。
And I just start crying. I just start bawling. Probably the first take was probably not usable. It was the sweetest note. And you know, on camera, Pam says, I'll never say what it said, but just know it was perfect. Well, I'll never say exactly what John wrote, but I will say just know it was perfect.
我开始哭泣。我直接放声大哭。可能第一条拍的根本没法用。那是最甜蜜的纸条。而且你知道的，在镜头前，潘说，我永远不会说上面写了什么，但只要知道那是完美的就行了。好吧，我永远不会说约翰到底写了什么，但我会说，只要知道那是完美的就行了。
So that's what was in the teapot note, guys. It was a note from John to me. A personal note about what it meant to work with you on the show. Yeah. About our time together on the show. And it was really sweet. Well, that would completely wreck me. Yeah.
所以，这就是茶壶纸条里写的内容，伙计们。那是约翰写给我的一张纸条。一张私人纸条，关于和我一起在剧组工作意味着什么。是的。关于我们一起在剧组度过的时光。真的非常温馨。好吧，这绝对会把我彻底击溃。对。
Oh, I love that. I didn't know that. Are you OK? Yeah. Well, crap. How do we talk about anything else that was so beautiful? I'm sorry. That was so beautiful.
哦，我太喜欢这个了。我之前不知道。你还好吗？对。好吧，见鬼。我们怎么还能讨论其他同样那么美好的事？我很抱歉。那真的太美好了。
I love that that was the direction that Greg gave. Those moments became very honest for us under that kind of direction. Yeah. And we all had little moments like that. That's a really big one, though. Well, there were those moments on the show that were surprises. Steve didn't know I was going to run up and tell him
我太喜欢格雷格给出的那个指导方向了。在这种指导下，那些时刻对我们来说变得非常真实。对了。我们都有过这样的小时刻。不过，这确实是一个非常重大的时刻。好吧，剧里确实有一些惊喜的时刻。史蒂夫并不知道我要跑过去告诉他
that basically that same thing, Steve, I'm going to miss you. All the things that I said to him. Oscar didn't know the note that Jeff Blitz gave me. So when all that emotion came, it was very completely out of nowhere for him. Yeah. OK. Well, jeez, Louise.
基本上就是同样的话，史蒂夫，我会想念你的。我对他说的所有那些话。奥斯卡也不知道杰夫·布里茨给我的纸条是什么。所以当所有的情感涌上来时，对他来说完全是始料未及的。对。好吧，天哪。
I'm sorry. That's OK. Where are we at in this episode? Well, we're at the moment when Kelly approaches Dwight in the kitchen. Kelly, that hussy. Oh, with her hair half down, half up. I know.
我很抱歉。没关系。我们这一集进展到哪儿了？嗯，我们到了凯利在厨房接近德怀特的时刻。凯利这个风骚的女人。哦，她那一半头发放下、一半头发扎起来的样子。我知道。
She goes up to my man and lays one on him. She does. And Angela sees it, and that is it. You know, a lot of people wrote in and commented that you're standing in front of a poster that says commitment. Am I really? Yes. Oh my gosh, I didn't even notice.
她走向我的男人，狠狠地亲了他一下。她真的亲了。然后安吉拉看到了，这就受够了。你知道，很多人写信评论说你正站在一张写着承诺的海报前面。我真的吗？是的。哦天哪，我甚至都没注意到。
That is so funny. I think I was just so focused on the scene. Yeah. Wow. Yes. Angela loses it, loses it. And this takes us outside. She's left the party, and now I have some stuff
太搞笑了。我想我当时太专注于这场戏了。对。哇。是的，安吉拉气疯了，彻底抓狂了。这就把我们带到了外面。她离开了派对，现在我有些关于这个场景的事情要告诉大家。哦，对。
to tell you guys about the scene. Oh, yeah. All right. 20 minutes, 16 seconds. The ultimate Angela pissed offness has happened. So here's some behind the scenes of this scene. You have a guy up on the roof, and he's got the soap snow that he's going to fall into your eyes.
好的，20分钟16秒。安吉拉怒火的巅峰时刻发生了。所以这里有一些这个场景的幕后花絮。房顶上有个工作人员，他拿着泡沫雪，准备把它洒进你的眼睛里。
He's going to, yeah, it's stinging. And then there's snow on the ground, because they've put real snow on the ground. We filmed this scene at the end of the day, and everyone had gone. It was just me and Charles McDougal, Randall Einhorn, and Mike Schurr. So it was just a kind of a skeleton crew at this point.
他要，是的，那会刺痛。然后地上有雪，因为他们在地上铺了真的雪。我们在一天结束时拍摄了这个场景，所有人都已经走了。现场只有我和查尔斯·麦克杜格尔、兰德尔·艾因霍恩以及迈克·舒尔。所以此时基本上只有核心摄制组。
Those are always some of my most favorite shoots. Yeah, me too. And we did not have a lot of time. We didn't have a lot of time to get this. The clock was ticking. Yeah, exactly, because we didn't want to go into overtime for everyone, and it was the end of the day.
那些一直都是我最喜欢的拍摄时光。对，我也是。而且我们没有太多时间。我们没有太多时间来完成这个。时间一分一秒地流逝。对，没错，因为我们不想让每个人都加班，而且当时已经是天黑收工的时候了。
And so Charles McDougal said to me, we're probably only going to do two takes, maybe three. But they gave me these ornaments, and my instruction was that my character has just lost it. Michael has ruined Christmas. Kelly has kissed my man. Ryan is the king of the party planning committee. Right?
所以查尔斯·麦克杜格尔对我说，我们大概只拍两遍，也许三遍。但他给了我这些小饰品，我的指令是我的角色刚刚崩溃了。迈克尔毁了圣诞节。凯利吻了我的男人。雷恩是派对策划委员会之王。对吧？
Yes. He said, I want you to take these ornaments, and just throw them and shatter them. They were written in the script as glass ornaments. They were not glass ornaments. What? Watch the scene. I throw them down.
是的。他说，我要你把这些小饰品拿起来，直接扔出去，把它们砸碎。剧本里写的是玻璃饰品。它们根本不是玻璃饰品。什么？看那个场景。我把它们扔到地上。
They bounce straight up in the air. What were they? They were like some kind of plastic composite, whatever. Oh, no. So when you look, watch it, you guys. You see them bounce in the air. I assumed, well, that makes sense. We did not have the budget to get special breakaway glass
它们直接弹向了空中。那是什么东西？它们某种塑料复合材料之类的，随便吧。哦，不。所以当你去看的时候，大家仔细看。你会看到它们在空中弹起来。我想，好吧，这倒说得通。我们没有预算去买那种特制的易碎玻璃
ornaments, and there's no way they would give you real glass. No. So these things bounced like a tennis ball. And so Charles is like, cut. And he goes, OK, two things. One, we need you to stand closer to the wall. Like, if you can in the scene, get as close to the wall as possible, because that's where the guy is with the soap.
饰品，而且剧组绝不可能给你真的玻璃。对。所以这东西弹起来就像个网球。于是查尔斯就喊：卡。然后他说，好了，有两件事。第一，我们需要你站得离墙更近一点。如果在戏里可以的话，尽可能贴近墙壁，因为那个喷泡沫的人就在那儿。
Coming down, the soap doesn't fall very far. So we have another take, and he's like, why aren't you breaking the ornaments? I'm like, Charles, they're bouncing. What are you talking about? He goes, can you throw them harder? I was like, yeah, they're just going to bounce higher. And I was like, OK, I got it.
泡沫落下来的时候，其实落不了多远。所以我们又拍了一条，他说，你为什么不砸碎那些饰品？我说，查尔斯，它们在弹跳啊。你在说什么？他说，你能用力扔吗？我说，行吧，它们只会弹得更高。然后我说，好吧，我明白了。
I got it. I have an idea. So I know now we're really running out of time. And Michael Gallenberg had taken the most awesome photo that I have. And it's the snow falling and me throwing the ornaments, and Charles McDougall in the distance watching me. Oh, cool.
我明白了。我有个主意。所以现在我知道我们真的时间不多了。迈克尔·加伦伯格拍了一张我最喜欢的超级棒的照片。那是雪花飘落，我正在扔饰品，而查尔斯·麦克杜格尔在远处看着我。哦，酷。
That's great. Michael Gallenberg, our set designer. Yeah, he took this photo. It was so cool. But anyway, here I am. We're running out of time. I got to stand. I got to get myself to the wall.
太棒了。迈克尔·加伦伯格，我们的布景设计师。对，他拍了这张照片。太酷了。总之，我在这儿。我们时间不多了。我得站过去。我得把自己贴到墙上。
I got to throw these ornaments, and I need them to break. And I have to shriek, right? So I throw them with, I said, I'm going to throw them harder this time. I don't know. So I threw them as hard as I could. They bounced up higher. I shrieked, and I just started stomping on them
我得把这些饰品扔出去，而且我需要它们碎掉。我还得尖叫，对吧？所以我用，我说，我这次要更用力地扔。不管了。所以我用尽全力把它们扔了出去。它们弹得更高了。我尖叫了一声，然后直接开始用脚踩它们，
and shattering them with my feet. Was that your intention going in when you're like, I have an idea. I can do it. I can do it. I was thinking, if I can't get them to break, I have to start stomping on them. Yes.
用脚把它们踩碎。当你心里想着“我有个主意，我能行，我能行”的时候，这就是你最初的打算吗？我在想，如果我没法把它们砸碎，我就得开始用脚踩了。是的。
So that's what I just did. That was just an improv in the moment. I just started stomping on them. Folks, notice I'm wearing my sass shoes. Whoa, that's the perfect shoe for this. I know. And so I shriek, I get to the wall. I'm stomping things.
所以我刚才就是这么做的。那完全是当下的即兴发挥。我直接开始踩它们了。伙计们，注意看，我穿着我的狂野高跟鞋。哇，这鞋简直绝配。我知道。所以我尖叫着，贴到墙边。我开始踩那些东西。
I rip the box apart. We got the scene. Let me tell you, ToneLoke89 is going to be very happy, because they wrote in with a fan question. What was that? One of my favorite scenes is when Angela screams and smashes the glass ornaments. What was it like to film?
我把盒子撕碎了。我们把这场戏拍完了。我告诉你们，ToneLoke89一定会非常高兴，因为他们发来了一个粉丝提问。是什么？我最喜欢的场景之一就是安吉拉尖叫并砸碎玻璃饰品的那个。拍摄体验是怎么样的？
All of that. Yes, exactly. But now if you go back and watch the scene, you guys, watch the first two that I throw. I think that's kind of from the first take. They bounce straight up. So when we go back up in the office, I have to point out that when everybody decides
所有这些。是的，完全是这样。但现在如果你回去重新看这个场景，大家注意看我扔的前两个。我想那大概是第一条里的镜头。它们直接弹起来了。所以当我们回到办公室时，我必须指出，当所有人决定
to go to poor Richards, Michael gets invited and the look on his face, it's better than any gift he could have been given. I know. And this is that moment where you're like, Michael has been just such a jerk this whole episode. And then you see this sort of sad wounded person that just wants people to like him.
去理查兹酒吧时，迈克尔被邀请了，他脸上的那个表情，比他可能收到的任何礼物都好。我知道。这就是那种让你觉得，迈克尔这一整集都像个混蛋的时刻。然后你看到了这个有点悲伤、受了伤、只希望别人喜欢他的人。
Yes, how much he needs people to invite him to have drinks. Like, he needs it. Or he needs his gift to be the most popular. Yeah. He needs that acceptance. Well, we have Michael's talking head at the end, where he's talking about Christmas and gifts. Here's a little fun tidbit.
是的，他是多么需要别人邀请他去喝一杯。天哪，他太需要了。或者他需要他的礼物是最受欢迎的。对。他需要那种接纳。好吧，我们在最后有迈克尔的单采，他谈到了圣诞节和礼物。这里有一个有趣的八卦。
This talking head was originally shot to be at the beginning of the episode. Oh. But when they were editing, they put it at the end, because Greg wanted to do kind of a montage of scenes and of people leaving of us out in the snow in the parking lot. And he was like, oh, wait, that talking head,
这段单采原本是拍摄放在这一集开头的。哦。但他们在剪辑时，把它放到了最后，因为格雷格想要做一个类似场景的蒙太奇，关于大家离开，关于我们在停车场雪地里的镜头。然后他说，哦，等等，那个单采放在这儿
that works perfectly. Because something that we couldn't do, because of the documentary style, you couldn't do a montage with a song. No. You had montages were set to talking heads. And we have had a montage with a song, but it's like the song playing in the car.
完美契合。因为有些事情是我们做不到的，由于纪录片风格的限制，你不能用一首歌来做蒙太奇。不能。我们的蒙太奇都是配上单采的。我们以前也用过配歌的蒙太奇，但那就像是车里在放歌。
Sure. Something like that. It has to be sound that is, what do they call that? Like a live sound. And a live sound. Yeah, something like that. Active sound. Yeah.
当然。诸如此类。那必须是那种声音，他们叫什么来着？就像是现场音。还有现场音。对，类似这样的。实况原声。对。
Before we get to the final scenes of the show, I just wanted to point out two lines that fans have quoted as some of their favorite lines ever in this episode. Oh, yes. Say them. One is, happy birthday, Jesus. Sorry, your party is so lame.
在我们进入本集的最后几个场景之前，我只想指出两句台词，粉丝们称其为这一集中他们最喜欢的有史以来最棒的台词。哦，快说。一句是，耶稣生日快乐。抱歉，你的派对太逊了。
Yes. And another fan favorite is, Yankee Swap is like Machiavelli meets Christmas. And I really do want you guys to check out the DVD, Deleted Scenes from this episode. By the way, we're not getting paid to say that. We just really think they're good. We just really think they're good.
对。另一个粉丝最爱的是，白象礼品交换就像是马基雅维利遇见了圣诞节。我真的希望大家去看看这集的DVD花絮。顺便说一句，我们说这个可没拿广告费。我们只是真的觉得它们很好。我们只是真的觉得它们很好。
And you guys, Oscar Nunez is so great with physical comedy. I did a sketch show with him before the office, years ago, in my 20s. We've known each other forever. He is a great physical comedian, but he didn't get to do very much of that on the office. But there is a scene in the Deleted Scenes where him and Creed move a desk, and he gets pinned in
而且大家，奥斯卡·努涅斯在肢体喜剧方面太棒了。我在《办公室》开拍前的一档小品秀里跟他合作过，很多年前，在我20多岁的时候。我们认识很久了。他是个伟大的肢体喜剧演员，但他在《办公室》里并没有太多机会展现这一点。不过在删减片段里有一个场景，他和克里德搬一张办公桌，结果他被
by the desk, and he has to get out from being stuck. And it's really, really funny. I want to see that. And Phyllis reveals in a Deleted Scene for this episode how she met Bob. Oh! She says that they met because he works next door. Oh, well, there you go.
桌子夹住了，他不得不设法脱身。真的非常非常搞笑。我想看那个。而且菲莉丝在这集的删减片段里透露了她是怎么遇到鲍勃的。哦！她说他们相遇是因为他在隔壁上班。哦，原来如此。
So there you go. They were right there together. And Kevin has a whole rap. He raps. Oh! A whole portion of a song. So really check out these Deleted Scenes if you can. They're fantastic.
所以就是这样。他们当时就在彼此身边。凯文还有整段说唱。他会说唱。哦！有一整段歌曲。所以如果可以的话，真的去看看这些删减片段吧。太棒了。
All right, let's talk about the final scene inside the office. All right, it happens in Michael's office. He's getting ready to leave. He's going to go downstairs. Meredith just walks into his office, takes off her top, and then Steve, as Michael, takes a picture, and then walks out.
好了，我们来聊聊办公室里面的最后一场戏。好的，发生在迈克尔的办公室里。他正准备离开。他要下楼去。梅雷迪思径直走进他的办公室，脱掉了上衣，然后史蒂夫扮演的迈克尔拍了张照片，接着走了出去。
I have a fan question. Well, first of all, Kate, I really wanted Kate to be able to call in for this one. I traded text with her, but she is starting a tour with Dancing with the Stars. Oh, yeah! And she's traveling today. She's on a plane, and she called me night before last.
我有一个粉丝提问。好吧，首先，凯特，我真的很希望凯特能打电话连线这一集。我和她互发了短信，但她要开始和《与星共舞》一起去巡演了。哦，对！她今天在旅行。她在飞机上，前天晚上给我打了个电话。
And she was like, Ange, I'm so sorry I can't come in. But she was like, I really do want to come in and talk about all things Meredith. So she will come eventually. Oh, that's good. I have a feeling you might know the answer to this fan question. OK.
她说，安吉，真的很抱歉我不能来连线。但她说，我真的很想来聊聊关于梅雷迪思的一切。所以她最终会来的。哦，那太好了。我有一种感觉，你可能知道这个粉丝问题的答案。好的。
Carrie Shabb said, or maybe it's Carrie Shabe, said, when characters flash each other, are the actors really flashing each other in real life? No, no, no. No. No. I mean, sort of. Sort of, I mean, it's still embarrassing.
凯莉·沙布说，或者也许是凯莉·沙贝，说，当角色们互相暴露身体时，演员们在现实生活中真的在互相暴露吗？不，不，不。不。不。我的意思是，算是吧。算是吧，我的意思是，这还是很尴尬的。
Even if I had to, like, be in a bathing suit, I'd feel awkward. You know what I mean? Kate was wearing pasties. Kate had things. She was kind of covered. Yeah, she had things over her hoo-has. Yeah.
哪怕我必须穿泳衣，我都会觉得不自在。你知道我的意思吗？凯特当时贴了防走光乳贴。凯特做好了防护。她算是被遮住的。对，她的私密部位贴了东西。对。
Steve is such a gentleman. He said, Kate, I'm just going to look at, like, your neck. Yeah, stare at your clavicle. They had no crew inside. Yep. Her image wasn't on any monitors, anywhere. That's right. And there was no chip in the digital camera.
史蒂夫真的是个绅士。他说，凯特，我只会看着你的，呃，脖子。对，盯着你的锁骨。他们里面没有剧组人员。没错。她的影像没有显示在任何监视器的任何地方。没错。而且数码相机里没有装内存卡。
So the flash goes off. It looks like Michael's taking a picture, but there was actually never a picture taken. Never a photo. So they were very, very mindful of taking care of Kate in that moment. Kate would go on as Meredith to take off her clothes. And quite a bit.
所以闪光灯闪了。看起来像是迈克尔在拍照，但实际上从来没有拍过照片。从来没有拍过照片。所以他们在那个时刻对凯特的照顾非常非常周到。凯特后来作为梅雷迪思也继续脱过衣服。而且次数不少。
Quite a bit. One of my favorite things is that Kate's father wrote her a handwritten letter. Oh, my goodness. And all it said, this is her father, who, you know, Kate is from Pennsylvania. And all it said was, dear Kate, stop taking your clothes off. Love, dad.
相当多。我最喜欢的一件事是，凯特的父亲写给她一封亲笔信。哦，天哪。信上写的内容很简单，这是她父亲写的，你知道的，凯特来自宾夕法尼亚州。上面只写着：亲爱的凯特，别再脱衣服了。爱你的爸爸。
Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh. What did Kate do? How did she respond to that? I was like, oh, man. Now, is that her dad having a sense of humor? Or is that him being, like, seriously, stop it? I think both.
哦，天哪。哦，天哪。凯特是怎么做的？她是怎么回应的？我说，天哪。现在，这是她爸爸在开玩笑呢？还是他认真地说，说真的，停下来？我觉得两者都有。
I think both. All right, should we talk about the parking lot? We're almost done here. Yes, let's talk about the parking lot, because it is definitely one of the most magical moments that I remember in filming all nine years. And we all say that. Yeah, people often ask, like, what were your favorite scenes?
我觉得两者都有。好吧，我们该聊聊停车场了吗？我们快说完了。是的，我们来聊聊停车场吧，因为这绝对是我在拍摄所有九年里记得的最魔幻的时刻之一。我们大家都是这么说的。是的，人们经常问，像，你最喜欢的场景是什么？
And it's always hard to explain, because sometimes your favorite scene, it doesn't seem like that exciting of a scene, but it's what happened behind the scenes that make it your favorite. And this parking lot scene is one of mine. Definitely, definitely. OK, so it's the end of the day. We have all of this real snow on the ground,
这总是很难解释，因为有时候你最喜欢的场景，看起来并不是那么激动人心的场景，但正是幕后发生的事情让它成为了你最喜欢的。而这个停车场场景就是其中之一。绝对是的，绝对是的。好的，所以这是在一天结束的时候。地上积满了真正的雪，
and everyone is leaving, and everyone's in good spirits. And it's really nighttime. It was rare for us to ever work past 6 PM, so we always got excited. To walk out in the dark, I think, we all felt like we were up past our bedtime. But also, you have to remember, this is Los Angeles. There's never snow on the ground.
每个人都在离开，大家的情绪都很高涨。而且真的是晚上了。我们很少在下午6点以后工作，所以我们总是很兴奋。走到黑暗中，我想，我们都觉得自己过了睡觉时间还醒着。而且，你必须记住，这是洛杉矶。地上从来不下雪。
So this is magical in itself, that we have a parking lot full of snow. And as we're walking to the cars, I don't know, like the shot you see, I'm actually in the front passenger seat of an SUV, but I'm only half in, like the door's open. But I remember one of the guys just picked up some snow and flung it at the other one.
所以这本身就很神奇，我们的停车场里堆满了雪。当我们走向汽车时，我不知道，就像你看到的镜头那样，我其实坐在一辆SUV的前排乘客座位上，但我只半截身子在车里，车门开着。但我记得其中一个家伙抓起一把雪，朝另一个家伙扔了过去。
And then they all started picking up snow and having this impromptu snowball fight. And everyone loved it, and they wanted us to keep doing it. But it was just sort of like us just all hanging out in the snow. We turned into a bunch of kids. We couldn't help it. We were up past our bedtime with snow on the ground.
然后他们所有人都开始抓起雪，打起了一场即兴的雪仗。每个人都玩得很开心，他们希望我们能继续玩下去。但这就像是我们大家一起在雪地里闲逛。我们变成了一群孩子。我们情不自禁。我们过了睡觉时间还没睡，地上还积着雪。
Fresh snow on the ground. It was so fun. And I have a picture of all of us together in the parking lot with Charles McDougal. And it's great. I love it. I covet it. I love that.
地上积着新鲜的雪。真的太好玩了。我有一张我们在停车场和查尔斯·麦克杜格尔在一起的大合照。太棒了。我太喜欢了。我把它视若珍宝。我太喜欢了。
I want to see it. Yeah. Well, this is why we have to make our scrapbook thingy, Angela. We do. We should combine. Well, that's what we need to do. We need to compile and combine all of our stuff
我想看。是的。好吧，这就是为什么我们得制作我们的剪贴簿小物件，安吉拉。我们会的。我们应该整合一下。好吧，这就是我们需要做的。我们需要把我们所有的东西收集并整合起来，
and then make it so that we can both have what we both have. Yeah. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Before we lose it all, we need to do it. OK. It's 2020.
然后把它做好，这样我们俩就能拥有我们各自拥有的所有东西。对吧？对。对。在我们把它们全弄丢之前，我们得把它做了。好吧。现在是2020年。
We need to do this. This is a goal for this year. I'm setting the goal for us this year. Well, you guys, she said it. Now I'm like, Jenna's going to put me to task. This episode was really special. I really hope we did it, Justice, because it means so much to us.
我们得把这事办了。这是我们今年的目标。我把今年这个目标定下来了。好吧，各位，她都这么说了。现在我觉得，珍娜要督促我完成任务了。这一集真的很特别。我真心希望我们没有辜负它，因为它对我们意义重大。
These episodes are almost harder for me than other ones, because there's so much emotion attached to it. There's so much that happens in the scene. Not only is it special to us personally, but it was a big moment for our characters. And just that moment at the end, that snowball fight, that is just a group of people who love each other, who are all getting to hang out.
这些集数对我来说甚至比其他集数更难，因为里面包含了太多的情感。场景中发生了太多事。不仅对我们个人而言很特殊，而且对我们的角色来说也是一个重大的时刻。仅仅是结尾的那场雪仗，那正是一群彼此相爱的人在聚在一起闲逛。
And we just happen to be on a TV show together. It's just a really special moment. And I love that they let that be how it ended. And that's really how it felt when we left this show, that we were just a bunch of friends who happened to be on a TV show together, because we were friends. And we are friends. Yeah.
而我们恰好一起拍了一部电视剧。这真的是一个非常特别的时刻。我喜欢他们让故事以这种方式结束。当我们离开这部剧时，真实的感觉确实就是这样：我们只是一群恰好一起演了一部电视剧的朋友，因为我们是朋友。而且我们一直是朋友。对。
And we're family. We are. So next week, we've got another big episode, Anne. Huge episode. I mean, listen, the rest of this season two is just going to be one momentous episode after the other. Next up is Booz Cruise with our special guest,
我们是一家人。我们是的。所以下周，我们还有另一集重头戏，安妮。超级重头戏。我的意思是，听着，第二季剩下的部分将会一集比一集更具重大意义。接下来是《酒水游轮》，我们的特别嘉宾是，
creator of the American Office, Greg Daniels. Greg Daniels is going to be here. We are super excited. We cannot wait to talk to him. Thank you, Greg, in advance. And Booz Cruise is a huge, huge episode. We'll see you next week. Bye.
美国版《办公室》的创作者，格雷格·丹尼尔斯。格雷格·丹尼尔斯要来做客了。我们超级兴奋。我们迫不及待地想跟他聊聊。提前谢谢格雷格。《酒水游轮》是一集非常非常重大的剧集。我们下周见。拜拜。
Bye. [? MUSIC PLAYING.?] Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer.
拜拜。[? 音乐播放 ?] 感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。
And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. [? MUSIC PLAYING.?] There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的助理制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码：Office。[? 音乐播放 ?] 这集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。